Welcome to your second drink of two weeks.
This is a fun episode.
You guys, we tried Scotch and Splenda in this episode.
I know.
Jenna, you brought it all in.
I don't want to ruin it for anyone who might be listening for the first time, but I reflect
very fondly on that.
欢迎来到两周通知的第二杯。这一集很有趣。伙计们，我们在这一集里尝试了苏格兰威士忌加代糖。我知道。珍娜，是你把这些都带来的。我知道。我不想给第一次听的人剧透，但我对那次经历的回忆非常美好。
Also, it was so early in the morning.
It was really early.
It was a little crazy.
We also talk about how much we wanted to interview Idris L before the podcast.
Yes, and we still do.
This reminded me that we need to still try.
and make that happen. I want us to put it on our manifest board. Well, the last time we checked in with him,
his people said he was on a set somewhere for five months. Yeah, I can't remember what that movie was.
而且，当时还是清晨。真的很早。有点疯狂。我们还谈到了在播客之前我们有多想采访伊德里斯·艾尔巴。是的，我们现在依然想。这提醒了我，我们仍然需要尝试去实现它。我希望我们把它写在我们的愿望清单上。嗯，上次我们联系他时，他的人说他在某个地方拍戏，要拍五个月。是的，我不记得那是什么电影了。
He's very busy. He's very busy. But, you know, maybe when the five-month project ends address,
you would like to come into Office Lady's Studio. Yes. All right. Well, listen, I have a quick bit of
extra trivia for this episode. It was originally titled Two Weeks Notice. And then it got changed to two weeks.
Do you think that's because of the movie Two Weeks Notice? You know, the one with Hugh Grant and Sandra Bullock? Two Weeks Notice. Do you remember that rom-com?
I mean, I remember hearing of it. I did not see it. Have you seen it?
Yeah. I went through a Hugh Grant thing. I was like, he is the funniest person I've seen in a long time in movies. And what's crazy is I was just flying and I watched Notting Hill again.
I love Notting Hill.
Oh, stop it.
他非常忙。他非常忙。但是，你知道，也许当那个五个月的项目结束后，伊德里斯，你愿意来《办公室女士》的工作室吗。好的。好吧，听着，我这一集有一个额外的小花絮。它最初的标题是《两周通知》。后来改成了《两周》。你觉得这是因为电影《两周通知》吗？你知道，就是休·格兰特和桑德拉·布洛克演的那部？《两周通知》。你还记得那部浪漫喜剧吗？我的意思是，我记得听说过它。但我没看过。你看过吗？看过。我经历过一段迷恋休·格兰特的时期。我觉得他是很久以来我在电影里见过的最有趣的人。最疯狂的是，我刚才在飞机上又看了一遍《诺丁山》。我爱《诺丁山》。哦，别说了。
I mean, I've seen that movie so many times.
The bench.
All of it.
Well, anyway.
That dinner party is one of the best scenes.
I would love to be in that dinner party scene.
So good.
我的意思是，那部电影我看了很多遍。那张长椅。那张长椅。所有的一切。好吧，总之。那场晚宴是最好的场景之一。我真想参与那场晚宴的拍摄。太棒了。
And yes, it's Hugh Grant.
It's two weeks notice.
It's like Hugh Grant is doing it.
It's just, you know, now.
Yeah.
You know what?
I feel like it was a decision here.
I am completely spitballing here, guys.
没错，是休·格兰特。是《两周通知》。就像休·格兰特在演它一样。这只是，你知道，现在。是的。你知道吗？我觉得这里有个决定。伙计们，我完全是在瞎猜。
There could be zero truth to this.
Okay.
I feel like this is like something a network suit would say.
They'd be like, you can't name the episode two weeks notice,
because there's already a movie named that.
You know what?
I actually had a whole other, like, thing in my brain.
What was that?
这可能一点根据都没有。好吧。我觉得这就像是电视网高管会说的话。他们会说，你不能把这一集命名为《两周通知》，因为已经有一部同名电影了。你知道吗？其实我脑子里还有另一件事。那是什么？
Here's what I imagined.
I imagined a bunch of dudes in the writer's room calling it two weeks notice.
And then Mindy Kaling walking in, Mindy Kaling, like...
Loves a rom-com.
And she's like, what are you doing?
That's already a thing.
And I feel like she had to school everybody.
Okay.
这是我想象的。我脑补了一群编剧室里的家伙把它叫作《两周通知》。然后敏迪·卡灵走进来，敏迪·卡灵，就像……热爱浪漫喜剧。她说，你们在干什么？那已经是一部电影了。我觉得她不得不给所有人上了一课。好吧。
This was my imagination.
I like both of these theories.
Okay.
All right.
Well, we also got this letter about a favorite moment from the episode.
is from Danny H in Duluth, Minnesota. Danny says,
Hi, office ladies. My favorite scene from this episode is actually a scene added back into the
Superfan episode. It's when Michael and Toby are in the break room.
这是我的想象。我喜欢这两种理论。好的。好吧，我们还收到了一封关于这一集最喜欢时刻的信。来自明尼苏达州德卢斯的丹尼·H。丹尼说，嗨，办公室女士们。我这一集中最喜欢的场景其实是超级粉丝版中加回来的一个场景。就是迈克尔和托比在休息室的那一段。
Michael is asking Toby for advice on what to do with his life and what his resume should look
like. I did not expect to be so tickled by this scene, but towards the end when Michael
is speaking directly to the film crew as if he's saying some inspirational monologue in a movie,
and it just makes me wheeze. Please, please, please, touch you.
on this scene as it is a gem.
Well, we love this scene selection, Danny, and you know what?
I think we should share it.
I'm going to set it up for everyone.
迈克尔在向托比咨询关于他的人生建议，以及他的简历应该是什么样子。我没想到会被这个场景逗乐，但快结束时，迈克尔直接对着摄制组说话，就像他在电影里发表励志独白一样，这让我笑得喘不过气来。请，请，请谈谈这个场景，因为它简直是瑰宝。好吧，我们喜欢这个场景选择，丹尼，你知道吗？我觉得我们应该分享它。我要为每个人做个铺垫。
Michael is coming to terms with the fact that he has put in his two weeks notice,
and he's kind of freaking out about that fact,
and he doesn't have a plan for the future,
and he goes back to the annex, and he's going to get advice from Toby, like you said.
Let's hear it.
Hey, Toby, I have a real quick question for you.
Sure.
What should your resume be and what should you do with your life?
迈克尔正在接受他已经提交了两周辞职通知的事实，他对此感到有点恐慌，而且他对未来没有计划，于是他回到附楼，像你说的那样去向托比寻求建议。让我们听听。嘿，托比，我有个很快的问题要问你。当然。你的简历应该是什么样的，你应该怎么过你的人生？
Okay.
Two questions, I guess. Fine.
No, no. No. I'm thinking to what I said.
One question with two parts.
Okay, well, look, the second part, you know, that's really personal.
I mean, only you can answer that.
So you're trying to get out of it? God.
Thanks for your help, moron.
好吧。我想是两个问题。好吧。不，不。我在思考我刚才说的。一个问题有两个部分。好吧，看，第二部分，你知道，那真的很私人。我的意思是，只有你能回答那个问题。所以你想逃避？天哪。谢谢你的帮助，白痴。
Okay, well, look, the resumes. I can really help you there.
I must read 20 a day.
Okay. Good. Write this down.
Born in a medium-sized town, Michael Gary Scott always knew he was different.
Okay, so we might start with, say, your most recent thing, summary of achievements.
What have you done here at Dunder Mifflin?
Changed things. Ushered in a new era of love and comedy in the workplace.
Hired many, fired few.
好吧，看，简历的事。我真的能帮到你。我每天至少读20份。好的。写下来。迈克尔·加里·斯科特出生在一个中等城市，他一直知道自己与众不同。好吧，所以我们可能从，比如说，你最近的一件事开始，成就总结。你在邓德·米夫林做了什么？改变了事情。在工作场所开启了一个爱与喜剧的新时代。雇佣了很多人，解雇了很少人。
Made money, lost money, learned to stop counting.
This is our moment.
This is our time.
This next part should be sung if possible.
That's Michael's resume.
It's brilliant.
It is brilliant.
I don't know how Paul Lieberstein made it through that without laughing.
赚了钱，赔了钱，学会了不再计较。这是我们的时刻。这是我们的时代。如果可能的话，下一部分应该唱出来。这就是迈克尔的简历。太精彩了。确实精彩。我不知道保罗·李伯斯坦是怎么忍住没笑场的。
Because for me, the thing that always got me with Steve is how, as Michael, he would take these pauses.
Yes.
And then say something ridiculous.
He takes this time.
You don't know what's coming.
No.
因为对我来说，史蒂夫总是能打动我的地方在于，作为迈克尔，他会如何停顿。是的。然后说出一些荒谬的话。是的。他花时间停顿。你不知道接下来会发生什么。不。不。
Well, I really have to thank Danny for suggesting that we go back and watch that scene because it's really awesome.
And because of Danny's letter, I ended up watching the whole superfan version.
And I'd like to offer another scene that was added back.
It's between Michael and Daryl.
So after Michael realizes he's not going to get a job someplace else, he gets his idea to start his own paper company.
And he goes down to Daryl's office for advice on starting his own company.
When Michael needs something from Daryl, it's maybe one of my favorite dynamics.
It's like this superfan episode has a Michael,
好吧，我真的要感谢丹尼建议我们回去看那个场景，因为它真的很棒。因为丹尼的信，我最后看了整个超级粉丝版。我想再提一个加回来的场景。是在迈克尔和达里尔之间。在迈克尔意识到他在别处找不到工作后，他想到了创办自己的造纸公司。他下楼去达里尔的办公室寻求创办公司的建议。当迈克尔需要达里尔帮忙时，这可能是我最喜欢的动态之一。这个超级粉丝版里既有迈克尔和托比的戏，也有迈克尔和达里尔的戏。所以我觉得我们需要听听迈克尔和达里尔的对话。嘿，双D。怎么了，迈克？迈克尔。哦，噢。嘿。你们能先回避一下吗？你知道吗？你可以留下。为什么我们不……这很好。我只是有个问题。你们在仓库工作。
Toby and it has a Michael Daryl. So I think we need to hear Michael and Daryl.
Hey, Double D.
What's up Mike?
Michael.
Oh, ooh.
Hey. You'll just excuse us for a second.
You know what? You could stay. Why don't we...
This is good. I just had a question. You guys work in a warehouse.
你觉得一家造纸公司如果拥有大约25个客户，需要多少仓库空间？希望有一天能扩张。也许像个车库？你会创办自己的公司吗？不。我可以投资吗？是的。我可以投资吗？
How much warehouse space do you think a paper company would need if it had like 25 clients?
Hoping someday to expand.
Maybe like a garage?
Would you start in your own company?
No.
Can I invest?
Yes.
是的。我的钱被套住了。我会敲定的。该死！见鬼。听起来是个稳赚不赔的买卖。哦，不是吗？迈克，我会回答你所有的问题，但我需要你知道一件事。
Yeah.
My money's tied up.
I'll tap down.
Shoot!
Darn it.
It sounds like a sure thing.
Oh, doesn't it?
Mike, I'll answer all your questions, but I need you to know something.
我在逗你玩。这听起来不是个好主意。明白了。好吧。你想创办自己的公司，而我只是试图劝阻他。我试过了。我真的试过了。所以就是这样。迈克尔试图寻求关于创办造纸公司的建议。他需要多少空间来放所有的纸？我喜欢达里尔真的很诚恳地试图劝阻他。我知道。哦，天哪。好吧，这个超级粉丝版还有一个很棒的系列，
I'm messing with you.
This doesn't sound like a good idea.
Understood.
Okay.
You want to start his own company, and I was just trying to disway to.
him. I tried. I honestly tried. So there you go. Michael, trying to get some advice on starting
his paper company. How much space does he need for all the paper? I like that Daryl really earnestly
tried to talk him out of it. I know. Oh, man. Well, this superfan also has a great runner of
就是人们对迈克尔离职发表看法的采访片段。他们是在汉克带迈克尔离开办公室并看着他开车离去之后出现的。广播版只有一个奥斯卡的采访片段，但在超级粉丝版中，我们更多人发表了看法，这很有趣。让我们听听。就这样，他来得神秘，走得也神秘。我想说我会想念他的。我想说。等他死了我会想念他的。我不会把精力花在每一步都想念他上。我会想念迈克尔。但你见过这个新来的家伙吗？
talking heads of people giving their opinion on Michael leaving. They come after Hank leads Michael out of the
office and they watch him drive away. The broadcast version has a single Oscar talking head,
but in the superfan version, a lot more of us weigh in, and it was fun. Let's listen.
And just like that, as mysteriously as he arrived, he was gone.
I would like to say that I will miss him. I would like to say that.
I'll miss him when he dies. I'm not going to spend energy missing him every step of the way.
I'll miss Michael.
But have you seen this new guy?
当上帝关上一扇门，他会打开一扇窗。你明白我的意思吗？哦，克里德又熬走了一个老板。是时候在盒子里放一颗弹珠了。所以我猜克里德桌上有个盒子，里面装满了弹珠，代表他熬走或经历过的每一位老板。太棒了。里面大概有五颗弹珠。哦，天哪，这对我来说真的很有趣。
When God closes the door, he opens a window.
You know what I mean?
Oh, Crete he outlives yet another boss.
Time to put a marble in the box.
So I guess Crete has a box on his desk, and it's filled with marbles for every boss he outlives or lasts.
That's so great.
There were like five marbles in there.
Oh, my gosh, that's really funny to me.
好吧，安吉拉·马丁也有一个糖果袋的替代版本，我们拍了，它是这样的。我不知道迈克尔的未来会怎样。他是一个身体健全、受过正规教育的人，所以我相信他会活下去。不过说实话，几年后如果发现他在我的教堂外乞讨，我一点也不会感到惊讶。我现在就能想象他拿着那个拼写错误的小牌子。我喜欢安吉拉幻想中他的牌子拼写错误这一点。她真是个刻薄鬼。哦，听着，总之，这一集的超级粉丝版
Well, Angela Martin also had a candy bag alt, which we shot, and it went like this.
I don't know what lies in Michael's future.
He's an able-bodied man with a formal education, so I'm sure he'll survive.
Truthfully, though, I wouldn't be surprised to find him begging outside of my church in a few years.
I can see him now with this little misspelled sign.
I love that his sign is misspelled in Angela's fantasy.
She's just such a bitch.
Oh, listen, bottom line, the superfan version of this one.
真的很棒。你会看到整段整段额外的场景。还有一个很棒的迈克尔采访片段，他透露自己养了一只宠物壁虎。我强烈推荐。我看到有人写信问关于壁虎的事。几个人想知道如果迈克尔养了壁虎，他会给它起什么名字？我当时就想，我不知道。好了，各位，希望你们享受你们的两周通知第二杯。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是
is really great. You get like whole extra scenes. There's also this great added Michael talking head,
but where he reveals he has a pet gecko. I highly recommend it. I saw people write in about the gecko.
A few people wanted to know if Michael had a gecko, what would he have named it? And I was like,
I don't know. All right, everyone, we hope you enjoy your second drink of two weeks.
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate ultimate.
Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give
exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the
办公室女士。哦，太好了。我总是想说早上好。我知道你想说，因为现在是早上9点30分。我知道，我正在喝茶。我正在喝咖啡。嗨，伙计们。今天我们要谈论的是《两周》，也就是第五季第21集，由亚伦·肖尔编剧，保罗·李伯斯坦导演。今天我们在演播室热身时，真的是在热身，因为这里非常冷。是的，这里冷得要命。我们一直在等它暖和起来。
office ladies. Oh, good. I always want to say good morning. I know you do because it's 9.30 a.m.
I know, and I'm having a cup of tea. I'm having a cup of coffee. Hi, guys. Today we are talking
about two weeks, which is Season 5, Episode 21, written by Aaron Shore and
and directed by Paul Lieberstein.
As we were warming up today here in the studio,
literally warming up because it was very cold.
Yeah, it's freezing in here.
And we were waiting for it to warm up.
我们一直在谈论我们有多喜欢编剧亚伦·肖尔。是的，亚伦，你太可爱了。我们很享受你所有的邮件，也很高兴能和你重新联系。你总是有最好的故事。最好的故事。难怪他们在剧集中用了这么多他真实生活中的故事。这是一个总结。上一集结束时，迈克尔告诉大卫·华莱士他要辞职了。
We were talking about how much we love writer Aaron Scher.
Yes, Erin, you're delightful.
We are enjoying all your emails and just reconnecting with you.
And you have the best stories.
The best stories.
It's no wonder they use so many stories from his real life in episodes.
Here's a summary.
At the end of the last episode, Michael told David Wallace he was quitting.
你猜怎么着？是真的。是的。他已经正式提交了两周辞职通知，他也放弃了任何工作。你有没有提交过两周辞职通知？我有。我也提交过。当你还在工作但每个人都知道你要辞职时，那两周是最尴尬的。是的。这是真的。你会有点混日子。我的意思是，我没有带着苏格兰威士忌和代糖到处走，但你确实有点敷衍了事。好吧，我在一份工作中提交了两周通知，在那两周里，我的工作是雇佣我的继任者并培训他们。所以我不得不进行面试，发布招聘启事，然后为我的工作为下一个人编写手册。你不得不做更多的工作。是的。我在那两周里做的工作比以往任何时候都多。我记得提交了两周通知，当我终于结束那两周时，我上了车，你猜收音机里放的是什么？
And guess what? It's true. Yeah. He has given his official two weeks notice and he has also given up on doing any work.
Have you ever given a two weeks notice? I have. So have I. It's the most awkward two weeks when you're at your job but everyone knows you're quitting.
Yes. And it's true. You kind of coast. I mean, I didn't walk around with, you know,
know, Scotch and Splenda, but you kind of phone it in. Well, I gave two weeks notice at a job,
and in that two weeks, it was my job to hire my replacement and train them. So I had to conduct
interviews and put out a job posting and then create a handbook for my job for the next person.
You had to do more work. I did. I did more work in my two weeks than ever before.
I remember giving two weeks notice and then when I was finally done with the two weeks, I got in my car and guess what came on the radio?
什么？《自由落体》。我就想，这是一个信号。你当时是那种感觉吗？是的。是那种好的感觉。不是坏的自由落体，是好的自由落体。是的。你终于摆脱了那份工作。听起来你并不喜欢它。我确实不喜欢它。你知道吗？在那两周里，我有点像迈克尔·斯科特。好吧，迈克尔在得知当前就业市场有多糟糕时，态度会发生转变。他突然开始恐慌，最后他要创办自己的造纸公司
What?
I'm free, free fall. And I was like, it's a sign.
Is that how you felt?
Yes. Like in a good way. Not a bad free fall, like a good free fall.
Yeah. You were done with that job. Sounds like you didn't like it.
I did not like it. And you know what? I was a little bit of Michael Scott during my two weeks.
Well, Michael is going to take a turn when he learns how bad the current job.
market is. He suddenly starts to panic and in the end he is going to start his own paper company
他会从试图招募邓德·米夫林的员工和他一起工作开始。但几乎每个人都拒绝了。除了帕姆。帕姆。帕姆。帕姆是唯一一个要加入迈克尔新冒险的员工。迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。我喜欢这个系列。我也喜欢。第一个快速事实，当我查看这一集的剧本时，它是在2009年3月26日播出的。那是我姐姐的30岁生日。同一年，我35岁，我们相差五岁。我记得我们为了纪念这些里程碑式的生日做了什么。什么？
and he's going to start by trying to recruit Dunder Mifflin employees to work with him. But pretty much
everyone says no. Except Pam. Pam. Pam. Pam is the only employee who is going to join Michael
in his new adventure. The Michael Scott Paper Company. I love this runner. I do too. Fast fact number one,
When I was looking at the script for this episode, it aired on March 26th, 2009.
That was my sister's 30th birthday.
That same year, I turned 35, or five years apart.
And I remembered what we did for our birthdays to mark these milestone birthdays.
What?
好吧。这是一个故事，我老家的家人说，我简直不敢相信这是你的生活。我总是说，这不是我的生活。这是一个时刻。这就像一件疯狂的事情发生了。拉斯维加斯的一家俱乐部。我记得这个。拉斯维加斯的这家俱乐部，我很抱歉，我不记得你的名字了。
All right.
This is a story where my family back home is like, I cannot believe this is your life.
And I always say, this is not my life.
This is a moment.
This is like a crazy thing that happened.
a club in Vegas.
I remember this.
This club in Vegas, and I am so sorry, I cannot remember your name.
哦，不。我很抱歉。因为我对拉斯维加斯的夜店知之甚少。但我生命中有一次，拉斯维加斯的这家俱乐部联系了我，他们说他们会飞来我的朋友、家人，任何人，给我们一次全额报销的拉斯维加斯之旅，还有晚餐。我记得这个，珍娜。因为我当时有个小宝宝。是的。我没能去。
Oh, no.
I'm so sorry.
Because I know so very little about clubbing in Vegas.
But this one time in my life, this club in Vegas reached out, and they said that they would fly out my friends, family, whoever, give us an all expense paid trip to Vegas, a dinner.
I remember this, Jenna.
because I had a little baby.
Yes.
And I couldn't go.
你没能去。然后你从拉斯维加斯给我发短信。所以我让我的姐姐和她的丈夫飞了过去，然后我让李的兄弟姐妹也飞了过去。所以就像所有的兄弟姐妹和嫂子们在拉斯维加斯见面，我们疯狂派对，这一切都在这次俱乐部体验中达到了高潮，我以前从未有过这种体验，有瓶装酒服务，还有烟花。烟花和纸杯蛋糕。上面印着我的照片。疯狂，太疯狂了。
You couldn't go.
And then you're texting me from Vegas.
So I flew out my sister and her husband, and then I flew out Lee's brothers and sister.
So it was like all of the brothers and sisters-in-law met in Vegas, and we partied hard,
and it all kind of culminated in this club experience, which I'd never had before with bottle service, sparklers.
Sparklers and cupcakes.
with my picture on them.
Crazy, crazy.
我必须告诉你。所以我没能去。然后第二年，同一家俱乐部。哦，天哪，拉斯维加斯的俱乐部。我们不记得你的名字了。我们很抱歉。第二年也是。这真的很有趣。
I have to tell you.
So I wasn't able to go.
And then the next year, the same club.
Oh my gosh, club in Vegas.
We don't remember your name.
We were so sorry.
The same next year.
It was really fun.
我们会弄清楚的，我们一定会把你在照片中标记在我们的故事里。我们会弄清楚的。第二年，同一家俱乐部。Privy？E上面有个重音符号？是的。是的。好吧。
We'll figure it out and we'll definitely tag you in a photo in our stories.
We'll figure it out.
The next year, same club.
Privy?
With like an accent on the E?
Yes.
Okay.
所以第二年，同一家俱乐部联系了我和敏迪。因为敏迪是6月24日，我是6月25日。他们说我们会为你们在拉斯维加斯举办联合生日派对，飞你们过去，全套服务。我和敏迪当时就想，哦，天哪，记得珍娜谈论过它吗？我们应该去吗？敏迪，你记得这个吗？我记得这个。然后不管怎样，我们没能去，因为我们有太多的变数。
So the next year, the same club reached out to me and Mindy.
Because Mindy's June 24th and I'm June 25th.
And they said we will throw you a joint birthday party in Vegas, fly you out, the whole shebang.
And Mindy and I were like, oh, my gosh, remember Jenna talking about it?
We should do it?
Mindy, do you remember this?
I remember this.
And then whatever, we couldn't do it because we just had too many moving parts.
但有一瞬间，我和敏迪在做发型和化妆时，我们想，我们要去拉斯维加斯过生日吗？是的。哦，天哪。Privy。Privy？我想是Privy。Privy。
But there was a split second where Mindy and I were in hair and makeup and we're like,
should we go to Vegas for a birthday?
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Privy.
Privy?
I think it's Privy.
Privy.
Privy。不得不说，晚餐很美味。好吧，该死。该死。赌场俱乐部区域。真的很酷。那是一个很棒的闪回。继续第二个快速事实，你提到了苏格兰威士忌和代糖。是的。尝起来像代糖，喝起来像苏格兰威士忌。迈克尔在第三季《鸡尾酒》中第一次提到这种饮料，当时他在大卫·华莱士家喝酒。那一集是保罗·李伯斯坦写的。这一集是保罗·李伯斯坦导演的。所以保罗显然很喜欢他的苏格兰威士忌和代糖。
A delicious dinner, I have to say.
Well, dang.
Dang it. Casino Club area. It was pretty dang cool. That's a great flashback.
Moving along to fast fact number two, you mentioned Scotch and Splenda. Yeah.
Tastes like Splenda gets you drunk like scotch. Michael first mentioned this drink in season
three cocktails when he was having drinks at David Wallace's house. That episode was written by Paul Lieberstein. This episode is directed by Paul Lieberstein.
So Paul clearly loves his scotch and splendia.
我找到了苏格兰威士忌加代糖的配方，我想我们今天应该喝喝看。闭嘴。你不会的。等等，我没吃多少早餐。这是苏格兰威士忌。天哪，珍娜。等等，萨姆，你知道这个吗？卡西？
I found a recipe for scotch and Splenda, and I thought we should have it today.
Shut up.
You're not.
Wait, I haven't had, I didn't have much of a breakfast.
Here's the scotch.
Oh my God, Jenna.
Wait, Sam, did you know about this?
Cassie?
卡西在拿冰块。这是代糖。卡西，你们知道吗？我不知道。好吧。然后我想。我早餐只吃了一个煎饼，只有一个。我想我们可以用我们自己的
Cassie's getting the ice.
Here's the splendor.
Cassie, did you guys know?
I didn't.
Okay.
And then I thought.
I've had one pancake for breakfast, only one.
I thought we could drink it out of our own.
办公室女士玻璃杯喝。我喜欢这些。看。好吧。哦，天哪，各位。你可以用洒水杯。我要用茶壶。好吧。萨姆和卡西可以用一些邓迪奖杯。
office ladies, glasses.
I love these. Look.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, everybody.
You can have sprinkles.
I'll have the teapot.
Okay.
Sam and Cassie can have some Dundies.
这是我打开代糖。哦，天哪。好吧，伙计们，现在是早上9点57分。好吧，这是你需要的东西。你需要一包代糖。好吧。哦，天哪。
This is me opening the Splenda.
Oh, my gosh.
All right.
You guys, it is 9.57 in the morning.
All right, so here's what you need.
You need one packet of Splenda.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
两盎司苏格兰威士忌。还有一些冰块。我的意思是，我不知道这会是什么味道。我们要在这里待一会儿。好吧。我要打开苏格兰威士忌。伙计们，这真的要发生了。我觉得这会很有趣。
Two ounces of scotch.
and some ice.
I mean, I don't know what this is going to taste like.
We're going to be here for a bit.
All right.
I'm going to open the scotch.
It's really happening, guys.
I thought this would be fun.
只有卡西知道，因为她得去拿冰块。我当时想，他们这里有冰块吗？我们开始吧。冰块进去了。搅拌，搅拌。好吧。只是让你们知道，这就是我父母认为我的工作是什么。不，别这么说。
Only Cassie knew because she had to get the ice.
I was like, do they have ice here?
Here we go.
That's ice going in.
Sturry, sturdy.
Okay.
Just so you guys know, this is what my parents think my job is.
No, don't say that.
我敢肯定这很难喝。我们会让你们知道的。大家都准备好了吗？等等，一秒钟。理性饮酒。好吧，准备好了吗？我们开始吧。干杯。
I'm certain this is disgusting.
We're going to let you know.
Is everyone ready?
Wait, one second.
Drink responsibly.
Okay, ready?
Here we go.
Cheers.
干杯。干杯，各位。干杯。干杯。哦，天哪，伙计们，还不赖。我不讨厌它。我不讨厌它。是的。
Cheers, everyone.
Cheers.
Oh, my God, you guys, it's not bad.
I don't hate it.
Yeah.
代糖。我没什么刻薄的话要说。我不讨厌它。真的很好。我不讨厌它。如果你在酒吧给我端上这个，我绝对会喝。下次我出去时，我可能会点这个。这尝起来像苹果蜂餐厅会有的东西。
Splenda.
I don't have anything snarky to say.
I don't hate it.
It's really nice.
I would totally drink this if you served it to me at a bar.
I am maybe going to ask for this the next time I go out.
This tastes like something Applebee's would have.
好吧，等等。珍娜，如果你在酒吧点苏格兰威士忌加代糖，我希望它倒闭。我去奇利斯餐厅点苏格兰威士忌加代糖。是的。哦，天哪。好吧，伙计们。干杯。干杯，各位。
Okay, wait.
Jenna, if you ask for Scotch and Splenda at a bar, I hope it shuts down.
I go to Chili's and ask for Scotch and Splenda.
Yes.
Oh, my Lord.
All right, guys.
Cheers.
Cheers, everyone.
好吧。搅拌它。搅拌它。萨姆，把搅拌带回来。哇，真的挺好喝的。迈克尔·斯科特确实有点门道。我真心以为这会很难喝，但我喜欢它。我也喜欢。
All right.
The chunking it.
Sam, bringing back the chunk.
Wow, it's really kind of good.
Michael Scott was on to something.
I truly believed it was going to be awful, and I like it.
I like it, too.
萨姆认为我们应该做一个名为《苏格兰威士忌和代糖》的衍生播客。我迫不及待想看看我们在那个播客里会聊些什么。我知道。好吧。第三个快速事实。这一集播出后不久，NBC办公室网站向所有订阅者发送了一封来自迈克尔·斯科特的群发邮件，内容是他要离开邓德·米夫林。
Sam thinks we should do a spinoff podcast called Scotch and Splenda.
I can't wait to see what we talk about on that podcast.
I know.
All right.
Fast fact number three.
Shortly after this episode aired, the NBC office website,
sent out a mass email to all subscribers from Michael Scott about the fact that he was quitting Dunder
Mifflin.
是的。这就是它说的。它说，作为邓德·米夫林斯克兰顿的经理，我学到了两件事。关于造纸业务的一切，以及邓德·米夫林是一家烂公司。我正在利用这些专业知识创建迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。我不能保证成功，但我保证会给你一生中最棒的时光。所以任何订阅了该网站的人都收到了那封邮件。
Yes.
And this is what it said.
It said, as the manager of Dunder Mifflin Scranton, I learned two things.
Everything about the paper business and that Dunder Mifflin is a sucky company.
I am taking that expertise and creating the Michael Scott paper company.
I cannot promise success, but I will promise you the best.
effing time of your life.
So anyone who was subscribed to the website got that email.
这太符合他的风格了。我知道这会晚点出现，但当吉姆说，你知道这是一个正在衰退的行业。迈克尔说，我几乎发明了这种衰退。就像，这就是他进入新业务时的那种能量。哦，好吧，听着，这就是我所有的快速事实了。一个关于拉斯维加斯的故事，一点苏格兰威士忌和代糖，还有一封来自迈克尔的粗鲁邮件。这是我们做过的我最喜欢的快速事实之一。
This is so in the vein.
I know it's going to come later, but when Jim's like, you know this is an industry on
decline.
And Michael's like, I practically invented the decline.
Like, this is the kind of energy he's going into his new business with.
Oh, well, listen, that's all I've got for Fast Facts.
A story about Vegas, a little scotch and Splenda, and a surly email from Michael.
It's one of my favorite fast facts we've ever done.
苏格兰威士忌和代糖可能对此有一定影响。好吧，我们休息一下，回来后进入这一集。我们开始吧。伙计们，我们回来了。迈克尔终于在厨房里掌控全场。他吸引了所有人的注意力。他正在告诉他们他是如何辞职的，他是如何去纽约辞职并告诉大卫·华莱士的，我想让你知道这被称为紫色开场白。
The Scotian Splenda might have had something to do with it.
Well, why don't we take a break and we'll come back and get into this episode.
Let's do it.
You guys, we are back.
Michael is holding court finally in the kitchen.
He has everyone's attention.
He's telling them the story of how he quit, how he went to New York and quit and told David Wallace,
I want you to know this is called the purple cold open.
在《办公室》的金赛编年史中。为什么叫紫色开场白？我会告诉你的，珍娜。安吉拉·马丁穿着紫色高领毛衣和紫色开衫。帕姆在开衫下穿着紫色上衣。凯莉穿着紫色条纹纽扣衬衫。奥斯卡的领带上有紫色方块，衬衫上有淡淡的紫色条纹。斯坦利的衬衫上有紫色条纹，领带上有紫色花朵。
in the Kinsey Chronicles of the office.
Why is it called the purple cold open?
I will tell you, Jenna.
Angela Martin is wearing a purple turtleneck and a purple cardigan.
Pam is wearing a purple top under her cardigan.
Kelly is wearing a purple striped button-down shirt.
Oscar has purple squares on his tie and sort of faint purple stripes on his shirt.
Stanley has purple stripes on his shirt and purple flowers on his tie.
凯文也有紫色条纹。我得告诉你，当我看到这个开场白时，我注意到了众多的宝石色调，但我没有像那样剖析它，我为你鼓掌。我只是想，发生了什么？艾丽西亚在哪里？就像，她在她生活的某种，我不知道，春之觉醒模式中。除了迈克尔，每个人在这个厨房场景里都穿着紫色。其他所有人都穿着紫色。
And Kevin also has purple stripes.
I will have you know when I saw this cold open, I noted the numerous jewel tones, but I did not break it down like that, and I applaud you.
I just was like, what happened?
What was Alicia?
Like, where was her?
She was in sort of like a, I don't know, a spring awakening mode of her life.
Everyone had purple on in this whole kitchen scene, minus Michael.
Everyone else had purple on.
嗯。只是说说，我觉得这很迷人。现在这一集要开始了。迈克尔拿着那些粘糊糊的、有弹性的手到处走。你知道，你的孩子们在县集市上得到的那些。然后他们把它们拍在窗户上，留下粘糊糊的残留物。迈克尔到处走，拍打着纸张，又把它们拽回来。他弄乱了菲利斯的头发。
Hmm.
Just saying, I found it fascinating.
Now the episode is going to start.
Michael is walking around with one of those gooey, stretchy hands.
You know, your kids get them at a county fair.
And then they smack them on the window and that leaves the gooey residue.
Michael's walking around, smacking pieces of paper, yanking him back.
He messes with Phyllis's hair.
我记得菲利斯在那儿笑场了。我也记得。这就是为什么你从后面看到她，因为她在笑。我喜欢他把它塞回西装口袋的样子，那只手在场景剩下的时间里悲伤地垂了下来。这也是迈克尔喝他的苏格兰威士忌加代糖的时候。是的。我们联系了这一集的编剧亚伦·肖尔，因为我们很好奇，是谁写了，“尝起来像代糖，喝起来像苏格兰威士忌”。是的，我们必须知道。
I remember Phyllis broke on that.
I do too.
That's why you see her from the back because she was laughing.
And I love how he tucked it back in his suit pocket and just the hand, like hung down sadly for the rest of the scene.
This is also when Michael is drinking his scotch and Splenda.
Yeah.
We reached out to writer Aaron Shore, the writer of this episode, because we were very curious, who wrote, Taste Like Splenda Gets You Drunk Like Scotch.
Yeah, we got to know.
我的意思是，这太棒了。他说那句台词是在预读剧本的推销会议上创作的。这意味着编剧们通常会一起工作，为每一集制定大纲，然后特定的编剧，在这种情况下是亚伦·肖尔，会根据大纲去写整集。他们通常有一周左右的时间。好吧，他们会提交草稿。他们会得到反馈。然后他们也会有这些推销会议。对。他们会得到反馈。有时几个编剧会被分成一组，为剧本的某个元素进行推销。是的。这正是苏格兰威士忌和代糖发生的情况。几个编剧聚在一起，他们说，
I mean, it's just too good.
And he said that that line was created in a pre-table draft pitch session.
So what that means is the writers, they would kind of typically work together to make an outline of
each episode and then a specific writer, in this case, Aaron Scher, would go off and write the whole
episode based on that outline. And they usually got like about a week. Well, they would turn in their
draft. They would get notes. And then they would also have these pitch sessions. Right. They'll get
notes. Sometimes a few of the writers will be put in a pod to pitch on a certain element of the script.
Yes. And that is exactly what happened with Scotch and Splenda. A few writers got together and they said,
我们想要一个非常有趣的笑话，用于迈克尔手里拿着饮料到处走的这个时刻。亚伦保存了所有的推销。闭嘴。哦，天哪。所有的，哦，天哪。它们是什么？好吧。所以，凯文说，那是苏格兰威士忌吗？是的。以下是迈克尔会回答的各种推销。是的，来自我办公室里消防车形状的瓶子。或者更好的南方舒适。或者，不，健怡百事可乐加水、冰块和苏格兰威士忌。
we want a really funny joke for this moment when Michael is walking around with a drink in his hand.
And Aaron had saved all of the pitches.
Stop it. Oh my gosh. All of the, oh my gosh. What were they?
Okay. So, Kevin says, is that scotch? Yeah.
And here are the various pitches that Michael would reply.
Yep, from a fire truck shaped bottle in my office.
or better southern comfort.
Or, nope, diet Pepsi and water and ice and scotch.
或者，这是无酒精苏格兰威士忌。最后，他们选择了那句，苏格兰威士忌加代糖，尝起来像代糖，喝起来像苏格兰威士忌。然后这就是他们最终为我们的剧本朗读草稿选择的笑话，这是所有演员得到的草稿，我们会大声朗读。我喜欢它。我的第二名会是消防车形状的瓶子。我也喜欢消防车形状的瓶子。因为我记得我爸爸有一种新奇的利口酒，我想它装在一个驿站马车里。我不知道，但它就放在架子上。好吧，那些额外台词很酷的地方在于，在剧本草稿上，如果一个，哦，安吉拉正在喝苏格兰威士忌和代糖。
Or, it's non-alcoholic scotch.
And finally, the one they went with, Scotch and Splenda,
tastes like Splenda, gets you drunk like scotch.
And then that is the joke that they ultimately picked for our table read draft,
which is the draft that all the actors got and that we would read out loud.
I love it. My number two would have been a bottle shape like a fire truck. I liked bottle shaped like a fire truck as well.
Because I remember like my dad had like a novelty liqueur that I think it came in a stage coach. I don't know, but like it just sat on the shelf.
Well, the cool thing about those extra lines was then at the table draft, if a, oh, Angela is having a sip of scotch and splendor.
我看到你了。因为我当时想，好吧，我们正在谈论苏格兰威士忌和代糖。这不是个笑话，伙计们。我们真的在喝它。啜饮。啜饮它。我们真的在啜饮它。那是你的，你正在啜饮。但我想要说的是，有趣的是，那些额外的笑话，那些他们没有放进剧本草稿的，他们会保存在那个糖果袋文档里。
I see you here. Because I was like, well, we are talking about scotion, Splenda.
It wasn't a joke, folks.
We're really drinking it.
Sipping.
Sipping it.
We're really sipping it.
That's your, you are sipping.
But what I was going to say is the interesting thing is that those extra jokes, the ones they didn't put in the table draft, they would save in that candy bag document.
然后如果一个笑话在剧本朗读时没效果，他们可能会去那里替换它，当拍摄草稿的时候。或者他们会让我们在片场做所有不同的替代方案。对。有时我觉得编剧只是想听听它们，纯粹为了好玩。即使他们知道我们不会用其中的任何一个，他们也会给你一张纸。如果我们那天在拍摄计划中有时间，我们就会做一大堆替代方案。这总是很有趣。太有趣了。斯坦利认为迈克尔应该开始寻找另一份工作。迈克尔说他有工作，安迪指出还有四天。是的，他说，你得在这里振作起来。好吧，迈克尔有一个采访片段，他不担心。我的意思是，他要做什么？他要做一点这个，一点那个，他要停止担心卡路里。
And then if a joke didn't land at the table read, they might go over there and replace it when it came time for the shooting draft.
Or they would have us do it on set all the different alternates.
Right.
Sometimes I think the writers just wanted to hear them just for fun. Even though they knew we weren't going to use any of them, they would hand you a page. And if we had time that day in our shooting schedule, we would just do a whole bunch of alts. And it was always so fun. So fun. Stanley thinks Michael should start looking for another job. Michael says he has a job, to which Andy points out for four more days.
Yeah, and he's like, you kind of got to get your act together here.
Well, Michael has a talking head where he is not worried.
I mean, what's he going to do?
He's going to do a little bit of this, a little bit of that, and he's going to stop worrying about calories.
所以在这一连串人们给迈克尔建议的蒙太奇中，拍摄草稿中有一个场景没能入选。凯莉走进他的办公室，她说，迈克尔，你要做什么？你知道我会做什么吗？我会搬到墨西哥。我会住在海滩上。我会裸体。我会做珠宝，有很棒的性生活。喝很多玛格丽特酒。她就这样滔滔不绝地说了一通。当凯莉在喋喋不休地
So during this whole montage of, like, people giving Michael advice, there was a scene in the shooting draft that didn't make it.
And Kelly walks into his office and she's like, Michael, what are you going to do?
You know what I would do?
I'd move to Mexico.
I'd live on the beach.
I'd be naked.
I'd make jewelry, have amazing sex.
drink lots of margaritas. She just kind of goes off on this whole thing. And while Kelly is rambling
说着她会做什么时，他正在桌子上雕刻。迈克尔到此一游。哦，天哪。他真的刻在了桌面上。我当时想，我们为了这个甚至没能入选的场景毁了一张桌子吗？不止我一个人注意到了。奥利维亚·C写信说，在删除的场景中，它们在DVD套装里，伙计们。我们看到了。我们看到了。迈克尔在桌子上刻了“迈克尔到此一游”。史蒂夫真的把它刻在桌子上了吗？奥利维亚，我有同样的问题，但你猜怎么着？兰迪·科德雷有答案。他说我们的制作设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格用完全相同相似的木材制作了一个匹配的桌面。哇。我知道。那是贴在实际桌面上的，因为我们是乱序拍摄场景，他们不能
on and on about what she would do, he is carving into his desk. Michael was here. Oh my God.
And he really carved into the top of the desk. I was like, did we trash a desk for this like
scene that never even made it in? And I wasn't the only one that noticed. Olivia C wrote in and
said, in the deleted scenes, they're on the DVD box set guys. We see. We see.
that Michael has carved, Michael was here on the desk. Did Steve really carve that into the desk?
Olivia, I had the same question, but guess what? Randy Cordray had the answer. He said our production
designer Michael Gallenberg created a matching desktop out of the exact same similar wood. Wow. I know.
That was laminated over the actual desktop because we were shooting scenes out of order and they couldn't
在这一集中有迈克尔雕刻桌子的不同阶段，因为那样就不匹配了。是的。所以他们只是有这个层压板顶部，他们会放在上面，然后他们会把它拿走。现在让我问你这个问题。好吧。这意味着维达，我们的剧本主管，会有一张图表。在那张图表上，对于每个场景，它会写着雕刻桌子，没有雕刻桌子。她会追踪我们什么时候应该看到雕刻。
have different stages of Michael carving into his desk in the episode because then it wouldn't match.
Yeah.
So they just had this laminar at top they would put on top and then they would take it away.
Now let me ask you this question.
Okay.
That means that Veda, our script supervisor, would have had a chart.
And on that chart for each scene, it would say carve desk, no carved desk.
She would have tracked when we should see the carving.
是的。但他们不知道他们以后会剪掉这个场景。对。所以我们有可能在整集中看到他桌上的这个雕刻吗？也许。你得离得很近，对吧？就像在他的肩膀上。是的。但我的意思是，这对维达来说可能很头疼。就像追踪所有这些。然后它甚至没能入选。我得告诉你，安吉拉，在2分48秒，我们有一个来自弗洛拉·K的粉丝捕捉。前台有一株盛开的植物。弗洛拉，好眼力。我知道这会让你的心感到快乐，安吉拉。我也看到了，弗洛拉。你知道，我们上次在前台有盛开的植物是在，海滩游戏。所以你认为这和帕姆有关吗？帕姆在这里会有她的时刻。她今天会有另一个时刻。她会再次绽放，就像在海滩游戏中一样。现在，我知道我们和史蒂夫
Yes.
But they didn't know they were going to cut this scene until later.
Right.
So is it possible that we can see this carving on his desk throughout the episode?
Maybe. You'd have to be close, right? Like over his shoulder. Yeah. But I mean, probably what a headache for Veda. It's like keeping track of all that. And then it didn't even make it in. I'll have you know, Angela, at 2 minutes, 48 seconds, we had a fan catch from Flora K. There is a blooming plant at reception.
Flora, good catch. I knew it would make your heart happy, Angela. I saw it too, Flora. You know, the last time we had a blooming plant at reception was,
beach games. So you think this is connected to Pam? Pam is going to have her moment here. She's going to have
another moment. She's going to bloom again today, like in beach games. Now, I know we talked to Steve
杜切勒谈过，他告诉我们这只是巧合，海滩游戏那次是盛开的植物，但史蒂夫·杜切勒，又是盛开的植物，帕姆正在绽放。我认为这是潜意识的。这就是那种群体思维。这就是我要说的。这是创造性的群体思维。好吧，迈克尔现在要搬进厨房了。我猜他饿了，所以他在找些吃的。他有点醉了，他要去，像，洗劫冰箱。谁没经历过呢？来吧。在剧本里，它只是说迈克尔拿出了一个清楚地贴着菲利斯标签的容器。但你知道他是怎么吃的吗？然后他说，菲利斯，这些都不在剧本里。哦，真的吗？不。史蒂夫只是即兴发挥了。哦，那太棒了。安迪进来了。
Douchererer, who told us that it was a coincidence, that it was a blooming plant for beach games,
but Steve Douchererer, again, with the blooming plant, Pam is blooming. I think it was subconscious.
This is that group mind thing. That's what I was going to say. This is creative group mind.
Well, Michael is now going to move into the kitchen. I guess he's hungry, so he's looking for some food.
He's a little tipsy, and he's going to go, like, raid the refrigerator. Who hasn't been there? Come on.
In the script, it just said that Michael takes out a container clearly labeled Phyllis. But you know how he's eating it? And then he's like,
Phyllis, none of that was in the script. Oh, really?
Nope. Steve just improvised that. Oh, that's so good. Andy comes in.
他想给迈克尔一些酒作为告别礼物。这其实是一个非常好的姿态。是的。而迈克尔根本不在乎。如果吉姆进来给他一瓶酒，迈克尔会很高兴的。我知道。但是，你知道，那是安迪，所以他就像，呃，我已经有酒了。我喜欢接下来的这个场景，因为迈克尔坐在前台旁边的沙发上，
and he wants to give Michael some wine as a farewell gift.
It's actually a really nice gesture.
It is.
And Michael just doesn't give a crap.
Michael would love it if Jim came in and gave him a bottle of wine.
I know.
But, you know, it's Andy, so he's like, ugh, I already have wine.
This next scene I loved because Michael's sitting on the couch by front reception,
一个男人走进来，他正在面试迈克尔的工作。是的，迈克尔有点在沙发上，读着小说。我放大了它。我试着看那是什么。就像一个马提尼杯里的女人。这显然就像一本浪漫小说。不，看起来像那些给女性看的关于，你知道，主张你的空间之类的书。是的，是的，就像一本励志书。是的，那是我看起来的样子。我想让你知道几件事。在4分16秒，盛开的植物在移动。它被移到了前台桌子的另一边。所以你可以更好地看到沙发。是的。面试这份工作的男人叫
and a man walks in, he's interviewing for Michael's job.
Yeah, Michael is kind of on the couch,
reading a novel. I zoomed in on it. I tried to see what it was. It's like a woman in a martini
glass. It's clearly like a romance novel. No, it seems like one of those like books for women
about, you know, claim your space sort of book. Yeah, yeah, like a motivational. Yes, that's what
it looked like to me. I want you to know a couple of things. At four minutes, 16 seconds,
the blooming plant is on the move. It's been moved to the other side of the
reception desk. So you can see the couch better. Yep. The man who's interviewing for the job is named
艾萨克·西尔维先生，亚伦·肖尔告诉我们，他是以亚伦的孩子艾萨克和西尔维的名字命名的。那不是很可爱吗？是的。他最初给这个角色命名为恩布里森先生，但保罗·李伯斯坦告诉他，不，以你孩子的名字命名。所以他就是这样得到了艾萨克·西尔维先生这个名字。他由大卫·格兰特·赖特饰演，他曾出现在几集《风骚律师》、《疯狂前女友》和《神烦警探》中，几乎是你所能想象到的每一部肥皂剧。大卫是一位不可思议的演员，我读了他的简历，他是27年的癌症幸存者。哦，哇。他写了一部名为《飞扬的色彩》的独角戏，讲述了他的癌症经历，他在过去25年里一直在表演，为癌症患者筹集了数千美元。
Mr. Isaac Silvey, and Aaron sure told us that he was named after Aaron's kids, Isaac and Sylvie.
Isn't that so cute? Yes. He had originally named the character Mr. Engbritson, but Paul Lieberstein
told him, no, name him after your kids. So that's how he got the name Mr. Isaac Sylvie. He was
played by David Grant Wright, who has appeared in several episodes of Better Call Saul, Crazy Ex-Girlfriend
in Brooklyn Nine, and pretty much every soap opera you can imagine. David is an incredible actor,
and I read his bio, he is a 27-year cancer survivor. Oh, wow. He wrote a one-man show called
With Flying Colors about his cancer experience, which he has performed for the last 25 years,
raising thousands of dollars for cancer patients.
好人警报。是的。好人警报。那太棒了。好吧，在这个场景中，迈克尔发现艾萨克是从费城一路开车过来的。迈克尔说，天哪，那真是太远了。艾萨克说，是的，好吧，这是少数几个招聘的地方之一。外面很艰难。
Good human alert.
Yes.
That's fantastic.
Well, in this scene, Michael finds out that Isaac has driven all the way from Philly.
Michael's like, gosh, that's a heck of a drive.
And Isaac said, yeah, well, this is one of the few places hiring.
It's rough out there.
你有点看到迈克尔脸上露出的那种领悟。珍娜，这个场景还有更多内容。太棒了。我在拍摄草稿里读到了。他有他的简历。艾萨克。迈克尔说，我能看看吗？迈克尔被震撼了。他发现艾萨克曾是他以前工作过的公司的总裁。哇。是的。现在他正从费城一路开车过来应聘区域经理职位。迈克尔被他的简历震撼了。他说，我可以保留这个吗？然后他
And you sort of see the realization coming over Michael's face.
Jenna, there was more to the scene.
It was so good.
I read it in the shooting draft.
He has his resume.
Isaac. And Michael's like, can I see that? Michael is so blown away. He finds out that Isaac was the president
of the company he used to work at. Wow. Yeah. And now he's driving all the way from Philly for a
regional manager position. Michael is so blown away by his resume. He says, can I keep this? And then he
你可以看到迈克尔脸上露出了恍然大悟的神情。珍娜，这一幕还有更多内容。太棒了。我在拍摄剧本里读到了。他带着他的简历。艾萨克。迈克尔说，我能看看吗？迈克尔被彻底震撼了。他发现艾萨克曾是他以前工作过的那家公司的总裁。哇。是的。现在他为了一个区域经理的职位，一路从费城开车过来。迈克尔被他的简历深深折服了。他说，我能留着这个吗？然后他
really starts to spiral and he goes to see Toby and ask Toby for resume advice. Like how to beef up his
resume. This made it into the deleted scenes. It's so good. Can we hear it?
Hey, Toby, I have a real quick question for you. It's about a resume. Sure. So we might start with,
so your most recent thing, you know, summary of achievements. What have you done here at Dunder Mifflin?
Regional manager, Dick Watt. Okay, that's your title. You know, how would you actually describe
what you did? Change things. Ushered in a new era of love and comedy.
in the workplace. Hired many, fired none, made money, lost money, learned to stop counting.
This is our moment. This is our time. This next part should be sung if possible.
真的开始失控了，他去找托比寻求简历建议。比如如何充实他的简历。这一段被剪进了删减片段里。太棒了。我们能听听吗？嘿，托比，我有个很快的问题要问你。是关于简历的。当然。那我们从最近的一项开始，你知道，成就总结。你在邓德·米夫林做了什么？区域经理，迪克·瓦特。好吧，那是你的头衔。你知道，你实际上会怎么描述你所做的事情？改变事物。开启了一个职场爱与喜剧的新时代。雇佣了许多人，一个没解雇，赚了钱，赔了钱，学会了不再去计较。这是我们的时刻。这是我们的时代。如果可能的话，接下来这段应该唱出来。
That made me laugh so hard. The scene continued. Toby said, how would you describe what you did?
And Michael has this speech, and it didn't make it in. This is Michael talking about himself.
Michael Scott always had a strange recipe for success.
Two cups of spirit, a half a thing of inspiration, two spoonfuls of love, a water bottle of danger,
a pinch of praise, a dash of hopes, a sprinkle of cinnamon, two pats of butter, a box of cake mix,
and a little bit of cooking oil.
Preheat of it.
Wait, what am I describing?
那让我笑得好厉害。场景继续。托比说，你会怎么描述你所做的事情？迈克尔有这段演讲，但没被用上。这是迈克尔在谈论他自己。迈克尔·斯科特总是有他那套奇怪的成功秘方。两杯精神，半份灵感，两勺爱，一瓶危险，一撮赞美，一点希望，一点肉桂粉，两块黄油，一盒蛋糕粉，还有一点食用油。预热烤箱。等等，我在描述什么？
That's his description of what he did.
Okay.
That talking head is very funny, but I have to say what?
I think I can tell you that's the scotch and Splenda.
Because it's so funny to me.
Is it not that funny?
No, but I've shared a drink with you before, Angela, and you're getting into that.
I'm tickled.
那就是他对所做之事的描述。好吧。那个采访镜头非常有趣，但我不得不说，什么？我想我可以告诉你，那是苏格兰威士忌加代糖。因为我觉得太搞笑了。难道不好笑吗？不，但我以前和你喝过酒，安吉拉，你开始进入那种状态了。我被逗乐了。
You're getting into that, yes, that territory where you giggle.
I haven't even had a full scotions blend.
No, no, you haven't.
And I just have to say one more time.
It's so good.
It's really good.
I know.
All right.
你开始进入那种状态了，是的，那种会咯咯笑的领域。我甚至还没喝完一杯苏格兰威士忌加代糖。不，不，你还没喝完。我只想再说一次。太棒了。真的太棒了。我知道。好了。
Let's move on.
Yes, let's.
We need to talk about this new copier.
I guess, you know, we have this whole runner about copier or chairs.
We never saw them get their chairs, but they have gotten a new copier now.
I did love that for the whole beginning of the episode, it was wrapped in like the blue sort of packaging, and no one said anything about it.
I just love how things are in the backdrop like that.
好了。我们继续吧。是的，继续。我们需要谈谈这台新复印机。我想，你知道，我们有关于复印机或椅子的整个梗。我们从没见过他们拿到椅子，但他们现在有了一台新复印机。我确实很喜欢这一集开头的时候，它被包裹在那种蓝色的包装里，而且没人提起它。我就是喜欢这种背景里的东西。
I do, too.
Pam has a talking head where she says that they deliver.
delivered this new copier, but they didn't set it up. So Pam's job today is setting up this
copier. This would do me in. I wouldn't be able to do it. I don't like reading instructions.
I don't like manuals. When I get any kind of appliance and it comes with the manual,
I just stashed the manual in a corner. This is reminding me of the document that we got when it was
time to do the layout edit of our book. You guys, it was like building a small Cessna. Are we
allowed to take a picture of that and put it on the pod because to me it looked like like some
我也喜欢。帕姆有一个采访镜头，她说他们送来了这台新复印机，但他们没有安装。所以帕姆今天的工作就是安装这台复印机。这会把我难倒的。我做不到。我不喜欢读说明书。我不喜欢手册。当我得到任何电器，如果它附带手册，我只会把手册塞在角落里。这让我想起了我们编辑书的排版时收到的文档。伙计们，那简直就像是在造一架小型塞斯纳飞机。我们能拍张照片放在播客上吗？因为对我来说，它看起来像某种
sort of scientific formula. It was all of these instructions for how to make a comment on the PDF.
And when I looked at it, my brain exploded and you got on the phone with me and said,
I can't do it. Lady, I can't do it. I will mess it up. So we got on the phone together and
every time you had a note, I read the document and I carefully made the note on the PDF. So if you
buy our book, Office BFFs.
Just know that we now know how to, well, we, Jenna knows how to do a note on an elaborate
layout craziness document, and I learned how to build a Cessna airplane.
Yeah, but we cared and we put that love and care into our book.
科学公式。上面全是关于如何在PDF上做批注的说明。当我看到它时，我的大脑爆炸了，你给我打电话说，我做不到。天哪，我做不到。我会搞砸的。所以我们一起通了电话，每次你有意见，我就读文档，然后小心翼翼地在PDF上做批注。所以如果你买了我们的书《办公室闺蜜》。只要知道我们现在知道如何，好吧，我们，珍娜知道如何在复杂的排版文档上做批注，而我学会了如何制造一架塞斯纳飞机。是的，但我们在乎，我们把那份爱和关怀投入到了我们的书中。
I'm buzzed.
I know.
While Pam is going to be putting this copier together, Kevin is constantly bugging her.
And there's a lot of Pam sass here.
Yeah.
I loved shooting this scene with Brian.
We shot it first thing in the morning.
They would do this when there were scenes at reception in particular that didn't feature the rest of the office.
我有点兴奋。我知道。当帕姆要组装这台复印机时，凯文一直在烦她。这里有很多帕姆的俏皮话。是的。我很喜欢和布莱恩拍这场戏。我们一大早就拍了。当接待处有不需要办公室其他人参与的场景时，他们就会这样做。
That meant nobody had to be in the background and you guys didn't have to come in so early.
So Brian and I came in first thing.
It was probably 637 in the morning when we shot this scene.
But I loved it.
We had so much fun and I got to sass him.
I think that we learned.
that in the accounting department, Kevin is tasked with all the menial tasks.
Like, go make photocopies. Go do this.
这意味着没人需要在背景里，你们也不用那么早过来。所以布莱恩和我一大早就来了。我们拍这场戏时大概是早上6点37分。但我很喜欢。我们玩得很开心，我还能对他耍贫嘴。我想我们了解到，在会计部门，凯文负责所有琐碎的任务。比如，去复印。去干这个。
You're so right.
That's why he cares so much about the copier.
It's his one job.
When Pam talks about how a copier goes through a lot,
I loved the runner of things that happened to this copier.
Oh, yes, we didn't talk about that.
It's so great.
First of all, Creed puts coins into it.
你说得太对了。这就是为什么他那么在意复印机。这是他唯一的工作。当帕姆谈到复印机经历了很多时，我很喜欢这台复印机发生的事情的梗。哦，是的，我们没谈过那个。太棒了。首先，克里德往里面投硬币。
So right there, Creed is like probably messed with all the mechanisms.
And Oscar's like, I think it's 75 cents.
So he keeps feeding coins into it.
And then, of course, Bandit chews on the wires.
And then Kevin dumps a whole cup of coffee over the entire copier.
It's no wonder this thing doesn't work.
I know.
I had a question for Randy Cordray at 5 minutes, 12 seconds.
所以就在那里，克里德可能弄乱了所有的机械装置。奥斯卡说，我想是75美分。所以他不停地往里面投硬币。然后，当然，班迪特咬了电线。然后凯文把整杯咖啡倒在了整台复印机上。难怪这东西不能用。我知道。我在5分12秒时有一个问题要问兰迪·科德雷。
When we see Bandit chewing on the copier cord, I was like, Randy, do we know who the
cat actor was?
Because you have this whole list of the cat actors.
It looked like Bandit.
Well, Bandit was played in this scene by the ever-reliable Milkman.
Oh, Milkman.
Randy said it took several days of training to get Milkman to actually chew on the cord,
当我们看到班迪特在咬复印机电线时，我在想，兰迪，我们知道那只猫演员是谁吗？因为你有一份完整的猫演员名单。它看起来像班迪特。嗯，班迪特在这场戏里是由一直很可靠的“奶牛”扮演的。哦，奶牛。哦，奶牛。兰迪说，训练“奶牛”真正去咬那根电线花了好几天时间，
which was painted with sardine oil.
Oh, wow.
The training of the cat, the labor, the transportation costs,
the cat rental for this episode, for this very simple three-second insert shot cost us
Any guesses, anyone?
Three seconds, a cat licking a cord.
Any guesses?
Cassie?
电线上涂了沙丁鱼油。哦，哇。训练这只猫、人工费、运输费、这一集里这只猫的租金，就为了这三个简单的插入镜头，花了我们多少钱？有人猜猜吗？三秒钟，一只猫舔电线。有人猜吗？卡西？
She guessed $2,000.
Sam?
I'm going to go big and say $10,000.
I'll hit it in the middle at $7,7,000.
$3,710.
Oh!
Cassie gets it.
Cassie wins.
她猜2000美元。萨姆？我要大胆一点，说1万美元。我折中一下，7700美元。3710美元。哦！卡西猜对了。卡西赢了。
Closest without going over.
And once again, we use Bob Dunn's Animal Rentals from Somar, California,
with Denise Sanders, our lead cat trainer.
Once again.
A simple little three-second joke.
It took somebody a week to make happen.
Yeah.
We are going to go to Jim's desk and over his shoulder we can hear monster sounds coming from Michael's office.
最接近且不超过。再一次，我们使用了来自加州索马尔的鲍勃·邓恩动物租赁公司，还有我们的首席猫训练师丹妮丝·桑德斯。再一次。一个简单的三秒钟笑话。花了一个人一周的时间才实现。是的。我们要去吉姆的办公桌，在他肩膀后面，我们可以听到迈克尔办公室里传来的怪物声音。
And I love this line when Jim says, it's monster.com, singular.
He knew. He knew.
We actually got a lot of mail about this bit.
Okay.
People wondered, where did we get the monster sounds?
Well, as it turns out, it was none other than our post-production supervisor's voice, Jake oust, making monster sounds.
Get out.
Yes, Jake!
我很喜欢吉姆说的这句台词，是Monster.com，单数。他知道。他知道。我们确实收到了很多关于这个梗的邮件。好吧。人们想知道，我们从哪里弄来的怪物声音？事实证明，正是我们的后期制作主管杰克·奥斯特的声音，他在制造怪物声音。别开玩笑了。是的，杰克！
I guess he just recorded monster sounds into a microphone.
And then our sound supervisor, Bobby Maxton, took the recording, added some reverb and some scary special effects.
And that is how we got our faky monsters.com website.
Jake, really good job with the monsters.
I agree.
This leads us into a Michael talking head where he says, if you work in paper long enough, you get to know the players,
and he's going to start calling some paper companies to maybe, you know, get a job.
Well, we find out there's only one on his list.
我想他只是对着麦克风录下了怪物声音。然后我们的音效主管鲍比·麦克斯顿拿到了录音，添加了一些混响和一些可怕的特效。这就是我们得到虚假Monsters.com网站的方式。杰克，怪物声音做得真好。我同意。这引出了迈克尔的一个采访镜头，他说，如果你在纸张行业待得够久，你就会认识这些玩家，他要开始给一些造纸公司打电话，也许，你知道，找份工作。好吧，我们发现他的名单上只有一个。
Are you ready for the saddest outgoing message ever?
Yeah.
Here it is.
I've had to inform you that after 40 years of serving the community, we are no longer in business.
Thank you for your support.
Yeah. Oh, that was harsh. That was Prince Family Paper, the small family-owned paper
that Michael and Dwight have clearly put out of business. The little girl at the end.
Bye. I'll have you know, they were uncredited, but we brought back the original cast members of
你准备好听听有史以来最悲伤的离职留言了吗？是的。就是这个。我不得不通知你们，在服务社区40年后，我们不再营业了。感谢你们的支持。是的。哦，那太刺耳了。那是普林斯家族纸业，那家迈克尔和德怀特显然已经让其倒闭的小型家族造纸厂。最后那个小女孩。再见。我要告诉你，他们没有署名，但我们带回了普林斯家族的原始演员来配音。
the Prince family to do the voices. That is Dan Desmond as Roger Prince,
And Emily Ray Argenti as his granddaughter, Rebecca Prince.
Like when I heard that again, I mean, I knew it was coming, right?
I knew it was coming.
But still, I was like, in his voice waivers, I was like, ooh.
I know.
Well, Michael needs to now figure something out.
So at 16 minutes, 49 seconds, he's going to start throwing stuff at Jim to get his attention so that Jim will come in his office.
那是饰演罗杰·普林斯的丹·德斯蒙德，还有饰演他孙女丽贝卡·普林斯的艾米丽·雷·阿根蒂。就像我再次听到那个的时候，我的意思是，我知道它要来了，对吧？我知道它要来了。但即便如此，我还是觉得，当他的声音颤抖时，我心想，噢。我知道。好吧，迈克尔现在需要想出点办法。所以在16分49秒，他开始往吉姆身上扔东西来引起他的注意，这样吉姆就会进他的办公室。
Yeah, he could have just called Jim, but instead he's going to throw a kush ball at him.
Well, Jim goes in his office, and Mike.
Michael's like, close your eyes because I'm going to tell you something.
And Jim will not close his eyes.
And this is when Michael reveals he's going to start his own paper company.
Mm-hmm.
Leading to your favorite couplet that we talked about earlier.
Yeah.
是的，他本可以直接叫吉姆，但他却要扔一个库什球给他。好吧，吉姆进了他的办公室，迈克尔说，闭上眼睛，因为我要告诉你一件事。吉姆不肯闭眼。这时迈克尔透露他要创办自己的造纸公司。嗯哼。引出了我们之前谈到的你最喜欢的对联。是的。
Do you know how the industry is in decline?
Do I?
I practically invented decline.
He goes on to tell Jim he has a name for the company and he wants Jim maybe to be a part of it.
He's very excited.
It's a big no from Jim.
I'll have you know.
At six minutes, 44 seconds, I spotted something.
你知道这个行业正在衰退吗？我吗？我简直就是衰退的发明者。他继续告诉吉姆他给公司起了一个名字，他想让吉姆也参与进来。他非常兴奋。吉姆拒绝了。我要告诉你。在6分44秒，我发现了一些东西。
What?
The desk.
No.
Do you remember in season three, the job part one?
I noticed that the outlet in Michael's office, the one under the big photo on his sidewall,
was upside down.
Correct.
And in that podcast, we learned that you can install outlets any way you want,
什么？桌子。不。你还记得第三季《工作（上）》吗？我注意到迈克尔办公室里的插座，就是他侧墙上大照片下面的那个，是倒过来的。没错。在那期播客中，我们了解到你可以随心所欲地安装插座，
and they still work.
Yeah.
You can put them sideways.
You can put them up and down.
Yeah.
I also said in that episode that I would be tracking outlets.
I'll have you know.
You didn't forget.
它们仍然能用。是的。你可以横着放。你可以上下放。是的。我也在那一集中说过我会追踪插座。我要告诉你。你没忘。
I didn't forget.
And if you look at that outlet, it is now facing up.
It is facing the correct way.
Tadda!
I kept my word.
Well, you did.
And the outlet is now up and down.
There you go.
我没忘。如果你看那个插座，它现在朝上了。它朝向了正确的方向。哒哒！我信守承诺了。好吧，你做到了。插座现在是上下的了。给你。
Outlet tracker, Jenna Fisher.
Mission accomplished.
Charles is going to interrupt.
Jenna is taking a drink of her scotch and Splenda.
I've been drinking water.
Busted.
What?
Yeah, I just saw you drink.
插座追踪者，珍娜·费舍尔。任务完成。查尔斯要打断了。珍娜正在喝她的苏格兰威士忌加代糖。我一直在喝水。被抓住了。什么？是的，我刚看到你喝了。
Charles is going to come in.
And once again, Jim is in the wrong place at the wrong time.
And he breaks up their meeting.
Yeah, because he says, Michael has given his two weeks notice.
Jim, did you also give your two weeks notice?
And Jim's like, nope, nope, nope, I'm going to go have a seat.
We just need to find a way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, okay.
查尔斯要进来了。吉姆又一次出现在了错误的时间和错误的地点。他打断了他们的会议。是的，因为他说，迈克尔已经提交了辞职信。吉姆，你也提交辞职信了吗？吉姆说，不，不，不，我要去坐下。我们只需要找到一种方法。是的，是的，是的，好吧，好吧。
So, I literally just said, I just want to say something.
We need to, I was going to say, we need to find a way to get to break.
But you said to get to drink.
That's what I said.
We need to find a way to get to drink.
You guys, I want you to know, it is 1048 a.m.
Maybe we should go to break and drink some water.
I think we should go to break and drink some water.
所以，我刚才真的说了，我只是想说点什么。我们需要，我本来想说，我们需要找到一种方法去休息。但你说的是去喝酒。我就是这么说的。我们需要找到一种方法去喝酒。伙计们，我想让你们知道，现在是上午10点48分。也许我们应该去休息一下，喝点水。我想我们应该去休息一下，喝点水。
We'll be right back.
Okay, we are back.
We have hydrated ourselves and,
is eating some cheese.
Jenna, drink some water.
We're going to be very serious podcasters now.
We're serious.
Don't worry.
我们马上回来。好吧，我们回来了。我们补充了水分，而且，正在吃一些奶酪。珍娜，喝点水。我们现在要成为非常严肃的播客主持人了。我们很严肃。别担心。
By the way, I wanted to start, before we jump back into the episode, I just want to give a big plug to B.J. Novak's new show on Hulu called The Premise.
It is so good.
I've seen every episode.
BJ, you are killing it.
Every episode is standalone.
It's like an anthology show with a different cast.
He's directed many of them.
He's written them.
顺便说一句，我想开始，在我们跳回这一集之前，我只想为B.J.诺瓦克在Hulu上的新剧《前提》做一个大力的宣传。太棒了。我看了每一集。BJ，你太厉害了。每一集都是独立的。它就像一部有着不同演员阵容的选集剧。他导演了其中许多集。他写了它们。
You know what I didn't expect?
So I just saw the first one.
BJ starts it.
Yes, he has an introduction moment.
Yeah, and I was like, oh my God, BJ.
I didn't expect to see you.
Well, they're great.
BJ is one of the smartest people I know.
你知道我没预料到什么吗？我刚看了第一集。BJ开始了它。是的，他有一个介绍时刻。是的，我当时想，哦天哪，BJ。我没想到会见到你。好吧，它们很棒。BJ是我认识的最聪明的人之一。
Him and Mindy are just...
Two of the smartest people in the room.
Yes, always.
And he has this way of articulating complex thoughts
in a really relatable way.
And brilliantly funny way.
Yeah.
He's the guy who wrote Diversity Day.
他和敏迪只是……房间里最聪明的两个人。是的，总是这样。他有一种以一种非常容易产生共鸣的方式表达复杂思想的方法。而且是以一种极其有趣的方式。是的。他就是写《多元化日》的那个人。
That's all you need to know.
He's also the guy that wrote the book with no
pictures. It's one of our kids' favorite books, and we've read it to them over and over the years.
The sort of scope of BJ's brilliance is really amazing. Yeah. BJ, we love you. We love your show.
Check it out, the premise on Hulu. And if you have a youngan, the book with no pictures,
you will love it. Back to the episode, Pam is on the ground with this copier manual.
And Dwight comes over. This is a really cool shot.
This was directed by Paul Lieberstein. This was his idea to put the camera on the floor with Pam.
这就是你需要知道的一切。他也是写《没有图画的书》的那个人。那是我们孩子最喜欢的书之一，多年来我们一遍又一遍地读给他们听。BJ才华的广度真的很惊人。是的。BJ，我们爱你。我们喜欢你的节目。去看看吧，Hulu上的《前提》。如果你有小孩，《没有图画的书》，你会喜欢的。回到这一集，帕姆正趴在地上研究这本复印机手册。德怀特过来了。这是一个非常酷的镜头。这是由保罗·利伯斯坦导演的。这是他的主意，把摄像机放在地板上和帕姆在一起。
I thought it was a really great idea. You know, at a certain point, there's only so many ways to shoot this documentary, and he found a new one.
I think Paul liked to have some of the artsy shots, because do you remember when Jan goes to comfort Michael and he's sitting in the train?
Yeah. You just saw the faraway shot of his feet. Yeah.
So I think Paul likes those interesting shots. In the next scene, Michael goes out.
Except Pam. Kind of sneaky. He wants her to help him make a order form for his new company.
Which is basically Dunder Mifflin's order form, but with Michael Scott Paper Company in the corner.
In place of Dunder Mifflin. Right. She's like, okay, all right, let me think about this. And she comes up with this way that they could kind of do this.
I can scan it. Yeah. And he says, I was thinking maybe we would just tape it. Put a little piece of paper over it.
我觉得这是一个非常棒的主意。你知道，在某种程度上，拍摄这部纪录片的方法只有这么多，他发现了一种新的。我想保罗喜欢有一些艺术性的镜头，因为你还记得简去安慰迈克尔，他坐在火车上吗？是的。你只看到了他脚的远景。是的。所以我认为保罗喜欢那些有趣的镜头。在下一场戏中，迈克尔出去了。除了帕姆。有点鬼鬼祟祟。他想让她帮他为他的新公司制作一份订单表格。这基本上就是邓德·米夫林的订单表格，只是角落里写着迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。代替了邓德·米夫林。对。她说，好吧，好吧，让我考虑一下。她想出了一个他们可以这样做的办法。我可以扫描它。是的。他说，我在想也许我们只是用胶带粘一下。在上面贴一小张纸。
tape it. She's like, okay. I feel like this is the moment that starts Pam's storyline of feeling
very easily replaceable because she's been studying and studying this manual and thinks she's kind of
had this great idea about how to use this new information and it's just like that replaced.
With some tape. At eight minutes and 41 seconds, I want you to know on Pam's desk, Nick is still in the office all day.
Well, the Post-it is still there.
Nick has been in the office for three episodes now.
All day.
Yeah.
用胶带粘。她说，好吧。我觉得这是帕姆开始感到非常容易被取代的故事情节的时刻，因为她一直在学习和研究这本手册，并认为她对如何使用这些新信息有了一个很棒的想法，结果就像那样被取代了。用一些胶带。在8分41秒，我想让你知道在帕姆的桌子上，尼克整天都在办公室里。好吧，便利贴还在那里。尼克已经在办公室待了三集了。整天。是的。
Nick in office.
All right.
Now we're going to get into this really wonderful scene in the conference room.
The Angela Kelly rivalry is going strong.
Kelly is talking to Charles about how she has to leave early on Tuesdays to pick up her little sisters from school because, you know, they're kind of like the Kardashians.
Angela's going to come in because she wants to show Charles that brochure for the accounting seminar she was telling him about.
Yeah.
Well, you remember he has.
尼克在办公室。好了。现在我们要进入会议室里这场非常精彩的戏了。安吉拉和凯利的竞争很激烈。凯利正在和查尔斯谈论她周二必须早退去接她的小妹妹们放学，因为，你知道，她们有点像卡戴珊姐妹。安吉拉要进来了，因为她想向查尔斯展示她告诉过他的会计研讨会的宣传册。是的。好吧，你记得他有。
as a degree in accounting. Charles is like, did Michael just allow anyone in his office at any time?
Okay, so this was in the script. I looked it up to see how much was ad lib and wasn't. And there was a
prompt for Angela and Kelly to talk at the same time. And we did add a little bit more,
but basically we both just were going to gush like, oh yeah, he was like, come on in. I felt like this
was super animated, Angela. Well, you know, she is turning on the charm for Mr. Charles
minor. I know. She said there was a Sunday bar at the accounting seminar, but she didn't eat any,
you know, just a trim. And then Kelly shoes her out and turns to Charles and says, yeah,
she's really special. You know, she's turning 50 this year. I was actually 37 when we filmed this.
会计学位。查尔斯说，迈克尔是不是随时允许任何人进入他的办公室？好吧，这在剧本里。我查了一下，看看有多少是即兴发挥的，有多少不是。剧本里提示安吉拉和凯利同时说话。我们确实加了一点点，但基本上我们俩都只是要滔滔不绝地说，哦是的，他就像是，进来吧。我觉得这非常生动，安吉拉。好吧，你知道，她正在为查尔斯·迈纳先生施展魅力。我知道。她说会计研讨会上有一个周日酒吧，但她没吃任何东西，你知道，只是修剪一下。然后凯利把她赶走，转向查尔斯说，是的，她真的很特别。你知道，她今年50岁了。我们拍这场戏时我其实才37岁。
I am 50 now. You know, when we were trading messages with Aaron Short, he wrote us about a prank
that Idris Elba played on the writers before he came to set.
Yeah.
Now, he actually said, I don't know if this was a prank that Mindy played on us,
pretending that it was from Idris or if it was actually from Idris.
But I guess they got this email that was like, listen, Idris gets really upset if you mispronounce his name.
And his name is pronounced Idris Ilba.
That's so ridiculous.
我现在50岁了。你知道，当我们和亚伦·肖特交换信息时，他写信告诉我们一个恶作剧，伊德里斯·艾尔巴在来到片场之前对编剧们开的。是的。现在，他实际上说，我不知道这是敏迪对我们开的恶作剧，假装是伊德里斯发的，还是真的是伊德里斯发的。但我猜他们收到了这封邮件，上面写着，听着，如果你们发音错误他的名字，伊德里斯会非常生气。他的名字发音是伊德里斯·伊尔巴。那太荒谬了。
And they wrote it out.
Idris Ilba.
Yeah, they sounded it out.
But then a bunch of them were like, I swear that's not right.
And so for the first week that Idris was on the show, all of the writers were afraid to call him by his name.
And then they found out that this was not true at all.
Number one, that his name is Idris.
And number two, that he doesn't get mad if you mispronounce his name.
他们把它写了出来。伊德里斯·伊尔巴。是的，他们拼出了发音。但后来他们中的一群人说，我发誓那是不对的。所以伊德里斯在剧组的第一周，所有的编剧都害怕叫他的名字。然后他们发现这根本不是真的。第一，他的名字是伊德里斯。第二，如果你发音错误他的名字，他并不会生气。
But I thought that was really funny.
Idris, was that you or was it Mindy?
By the way, Idris, we have.
tried to reach out to you. We don't know how to get a hold of you. We'd love for you to be on the show.
We did find some of your peeps, but they said you're, you're busy. Very busy, I guess. You're
making two movies and you're promoting another movie. You're busy. We're here for you, Idris.
Anytime. If you would like a Scotch and Splenda. Where are your gals? With two gals who
loved to Google. We're here for you. Well, Charles has a talking head where he just kind of owns it.
但我认为那真的很有趣。伊德里斯，那是你还是敏迪？顺便说一句，伊德里斯，我们尝试联系你。我们不知道怎么联系你。我们很希望你能来参加节目。我们确实找到了你的一些伙伴，但他们说你，你很忙。非常忙，我想。你在拍两部电影，还在宣传另一部电影。你很忙。我们在这里等你，伊德里斯。随时。如果你想要一杯苏格兰威士忌加代糖。你的姑娘们在哪里？和两个喜欢谷歌的姑娘在一起。我们在这里等你。好吧，查尔斯有一个采访镜头，他只是有点掌控全局。
He's like, look, I know the effect I have on women. That's a meme.
Yeah. It's so funny. Well, Aaron Scherer shared with us, you guys, that that talking head was inspired from a real interaction he had. He said there was an actor he was working with, no names. He wouldn't divulge the name, Big Star, who they were pitching a joke to. And the actor was like, this joke would never work because, I mean, I know the effect I have on women. And Aaron saved that. It went in his brain. And Charles had it in a talking head. I really wish.
We knew the actor, but Aaron, gentleman that he is, did not say.
Maybe if we took him out for a scotch and Splenda, he would tell us.
Immediately after this scene, Kelly is not going to give up, guys.
And in the deleted scenes, there's a little bit of what I want to call a flirty in the break room.
Ooh.
Excuse me.
他说，看，我知道我对女性的影响。那是个梗。是的。太搞笑了。好吧，亚伦·谢勒和我们分享说，伙计们，那个采访镜头灵感来自于他的一次真实互动。他说有一个他合作过的演员，不提名字。他不会透露名字，大明星，他们向他推销一个笑话。那个演员说，这个笑话永远不会奏效，因为，我的意思是，我知道我对女性的影响。亚伦记住了。它进入了他的大脑。查尔斯在采访镜头里就有了它。我真希望我们知道那个演员是谁，但亚伦，作为绅士，没有说。也许如果我们带他出去喝杯苏格兰威士忌加代糖，他会告诉我们。在这场戏之后，凯利不会放弃，伙计们。在删减片段里，有一点我想称之为休息室里的调情。噢。打扰一下。
Hello.
Hey.
Having a nice stay here?
Great.
You must be from Jamba Juice.
What's that?
It's a juice company because you're a smoothie.
Okay.
你好。嘿。在这里待得愉快吗？太棒了。你一定是来自Jamba Juice。那是什么？那是一家果汁公司，因为你是个冰沙。好吧。
I'm sorry.
Not about that.
Shut up, shut up, shut up.
So she has this really lame pickup line and then immediately just hates herself and goes in the corner and is like,
How? Why don't I do that?
Well, this leads us into a scene that I will call awkward in the kitchen.
Oh, so awkward.
Michael is still trying to recruit people for his business.
对不起。不是关于那个。闭嘴，闭嘴，闭嘴。所以她有这句非常蹩脚的搭讪台词，然后立刻就讨厌自己，躲在角落里说，怎么会？我为什么要做那个？好吧，这引出了我称之为厨房里尴尬的一幕。噢，太尴尬了。迈克尔还在试图招募人员加入他的公司。
And Andy does that thing, you know, that people do when they're uncomfortable.
They either sing their answer or they do it accent.
I think I'm the accent person.
I sing stuff.
Yeah, when you don't want to like really tip your hand.
Yeah.
So Andy's like, oh, oh, interesting idea.
Like he does some ridiculous accent.
安迪做了那件事，你知道，人们在不舒服时会做的事。他们要么唱出答案，要么用口音。我想我是那个用口音的人。我唱歌。是的，当你不想真正透露你的底牌时。是的。所以安迪说，哦，哦，有趣的想法。就像他用某种荒谬的口音。
But you would be like, that's a very interesting offer.
Yeah.
I mean, the other day I did it while we were working together.
when we were working on that document.
Oh, yeah.
I was like, this PDF editing is difficult.
And then I was like, are you okay?
Because it sounds like you're about to spiral.
但你会说，那是一个非常有趣的提议。是的。我的意思是，前几天我们一起工作时我也做了。当我们处理那个文档时。哦，是的。我说，这个PDF编辑太难了。然后我说，你还好吗？因为听起来你快要失控了。
I was like, yeah.
Well, it gets only more cringy because now Dwight comes in.
But Michael does not ask Dwight to join his company,
but it is also clear that Dwight wouldn't say yes anyway.
Yeah, so he's like, I've got the farm and a thing.
And let's put a pin in it.
Yeah, let's definitely put a pin in that.
Yeah. Well, we got a lot of mail about this kitchen scene. A lot of people felt like it was out of character for Dwight to not want to join Michael's paper company. And also, people wondered, why didn't Michael want him to join? And I just didn't know if we wanted to discuss. I have my thoughts. Let me hear them.
我说，是的。好吧，这只会变得更令人尴尬，因为现在德怀特进来了。但迈克尔没有邀请德怀特加入他的公司，但也很明显德怀特无论如何都不会答应。是的，所以他说，我有农场和别的事。让我们先搁置一下。是的，让我们一定要搁置一下。好吧，我们收到了很多关于这场厨房戏的邮件。很多人觉得德怀特不想加入迈克尔的造纸公司不符合他的人设。而且，人们想知道，为什么迈克尔不想让他加入？我只是不知道我们是否想讨论。我有我的想法。让我听听。
Dwight is a survivalist, and he doesn't think Michael's company is going to survive.
So ultimately, even though he loves Michael, he's not going to go somewhere where he won't survive, right?
Yeah.
So I think he's very practical, so he's not going to go with Michael.
But I'm not sure why Michael doesn't want Dwight.
Do you have any thoughts?
You know, that is a really good question.
I definitely see why Dwight would say no.
德怀特是一个生存主义者，他不认为迈克尔的公司能生存下去。所以最终，尽管他爱迈克尔，但他不会去一个他无法生存的地方，对吧？是的。所以我认为他非常务实，所以他不会和迈克尔一起走。但我不知道为什么迈克尔不想要德怀特。你有什么想法吗？你知道，那是一个非常好的问题。我绝对明白为什么德怀特会说不。
But why Michael doesn't ask, I'm not quite sure.
Yeah.
Do you guys have theories?
Yeah, send us your theories.
We'll add them to a revisited.
But Michael is going to ask Oscar.
And the way he's going to do that is by putting a note in his sandwich.
A piece of paper that he bites into.
但为什么迈克尔不邀请，我不太确定。是的。你们有理论吗？是的，把你们的理论发给我们。我们会把它们加到重温中。但迈克尔要邀请奥斯卡。他邀请的方式是把一张纸条放进他的三明治里。他咬了一口的一张纸。
Don't worry, it's sterile.
Just saying sterile doesn't mean it's sterile.
I loved that line.
It's like just saying bankrupt doesn't mean he declared bankruptcy.
Exactly.
Michael gets Oscar to meet him outside.
And Oscar immediately starts offering very practical advice
about how most new businesses don't turn a business.
别担心，它是无菌的。只是说无菌并不意味着它是无菌的。我很喜欢那句台词。就像只是说破产并不意味着他宣布破产。完全正确。迈克尔让奥斯卡在外面见他。奥斯卡立刻开始提供非常务实的建议，关于大多数新企业在头两年内不会盈利。而且，你知道，他负担得起吗？他负担得起两年不赚钱吗？对。好吧，迈克尔说，嘿，嘿，别再劝我了。你被录用了。带着你所有的数字术语。但最终，奥斯卡拒绝了。这意味着他必须去找斯坦利，他要在洗手间外面跟踪他。外面？他在里面。我不知道小便池是怎么工作的，但我猜他走过去时他正在小便，因为斯坦利说，我正在小便。迈克尔一直在和他说话。斯坦利说，不。
profit for the first two years. And, you know, can he afford that? Can he afford to make no money for two
years? Right. Well, Michael's like, hey, hey, stop convincing me. You got the job. With all your number
lingo. But ultimately, Oscar's a no. And that means that he has to move on to Stanley, who he's going to
stalk outside the bathroom. Outside? He's inside. I guess outside the stall. I don't know how urinals work,
but I imagine he walked up while he was just peeing
because Stanley's like, I'm urinating.
Michael keeps talking to him.
Stanley's like, no.
迈克尔随后有一个非常悲伤的采访镜头，他说，你知道吗？没人答应去参加舞会，但我还是玩得很开心。猜猜怎么着？什么？帕姆修好了复印机。四个小时后，她做到了。
Michael has then a very sad talking head
where he's like, you know what?
No one said yes to prom,
but I still had a good time.
Guess what?
What?
Pam fixed the copier.
After four hours, she did it.
她没有让它打败她。不，她没有。她了解这台机器的一切。菲利斯要复印一张纸。帕姆说，成功了吗？怎么样？菲利斯说，很好。很好。所以整个复印机故事情节让我感觉非常熟悉。做过很多临时工作，在现实生活中修过很多复印机，我觉得这就像是一个也有这种个人经历的人写的。是的。所以我不得不
She didn't let it beat her.
No, she did not.
She knows everything about this machine.
Phyllis is going to copy a piece of paper.
And Pam is like,
did it work? How is it? And Phyllis is like, fine. Fine. So this whole copier storyline felt very
familiar to me. Having worked many temp jobs, having fixed many copiers in my real life, and it just
felt to me like it was written by someone who also had this personal knowledge. Yeah. So I had to
问亚伦，你有复印机的经验吗？你知道，因为太多了。所以，他的很多真实生活故事都写进了我们的剧本里，比如跑过测速仪。是的，整个复印机故事有这么多细节。事实证明，是的，是的，他告诉我们，当他在纽约做一个挣扎的单口喜剧演员时，他在很多办公室做过临时工，他很快了解到，如果你能修好复印机，你就掌握了权力。是的。他实际上说，引用一下，“你就像一个办公室魔术师，一个大卫·科波菲尔，打开了神秘的柜子。”我觉得只有做过复印机工作的人才能完全理解。所以我完全理解。
ask Aaron, have you had experience with copiers? You know, because so much. So,
many of his real-life stories have wound up in our scripts, like running past the speed meter.
Yeah, and this whole copier story has so many details. So as it turns out, yes, yes, he told us that he
temped in a ton of offices when he was a struggling stand-up in New York, and he quickly learned
that if you could unjam the copier, you held the power. Yeah. He actually said, quote,
you were like an office magician, a David Copperfield, opening the cabinet of mysteries.
And only a person who has done the copier thing, I feel like totally gets it.
So I totally get it.
他说他实际上会复印用户手册，带回家，在一周内读完。那部分真的触动了我。他会像从手册里学到一切一样。亚伦，我懂你。谢谢你为帕姆写了这个梗。因为在表演这个复印机故事时，我能够借鉴很多我的真实生活经验。好吧，我不知道。迈克尔把虚假的订单表格留在复印机里了吗？查尔斯发现了它。他是怎么发现的？我们不知道。但他要叫汉克，他们要护送他离开大楼。
He said that he would actually copy the user manuals and take them home and read them over the week.
That's the part that really got me.
He would like learn everything from the manual.
Aaron, I feel you.
Thank you for writing this runner for Pam.
because I was able to draw on a lot of my real-life experience when it came to performing this copier story.
Well, I don't know. Did Michael leave the faky order form in the copier?
Charles finds it. How does he find it? We don't know. But he's going to get Hank and they're going to escort him out the building.
我很抱歉。我不确定是否有一个我比休·丹恩饰演的汉克更喜欢的常驻角色。我知道。我知道。当迈克尔说，汉克，来吧，护送查尔斯出去。汉克说，来吧，伙计。就来吧。他太棒了。太棒了。迈克尔真的很想做一个告别演讲。查尔斯不会让他这么做的。每个人都在他离开时看着他。他从车里大喊大叫，对吧？他从停车场大喊。每个人都在往下看。他们说，他在说什么？我们听不见他在说什么。这就是剧本里写的。好了。迈克尔走向他的车。每个人都在上面的会议室里看着。
I am sorry. I am not sure that there is a recurring character that I love more than Hugh Dane as Hank.
I know. I know. When Michael's like,
Hank, come on, escort Charles out. And Hank's like, come on, man. Just come on. He's so good.
So good. Michael really wanted to make a farewell speech. Charles is not going to have that.
And everyone watches him as he leaves. And he's like yelling things from his car, right? He's yelling from the parking lot. And everyone's looking down. And they're like, what's he's saying? We can't hear what he's saying. This is what it's said in the script.
All right.
Michael walks toward his car.
Everybody watches from the conference room above.
迈克尔停在他的车旁，抬头看着邓德·米夫林的窗户。然后他大喊这个。就是这样。这是再见。永远。啊！外面天气真好。自由！
Michael stops at his car and looks up at the Dunder Mifflin windows.
And then he yells this.
This is it.
This is goodbye.
Forever.
Ah!
It's such a nice day out here.
Freedom!
我已经准备好了。我现在可以做到了。我要去喝咖啡。这就是剧本里的内容。然后它说他尖叫着轮胎开车走了。摄像机跟着他的车，迈克尔把车停在拐角处不远的地方，下车，溜回停车场，进入大楼。我们听到了很多关于迈克尔离开的意见。我最喜欢的大概是托比。嗯哼。
I'm already.
I can do it now.
I'm going to go for coffee.
That is what was in the script.
And then it says he screeches his tires and drives off.
the camera follows his car, Michael parks just a short distance around the corner, gets out of his car, sneaks back into the parking lot and into the building.
We get to hear a lot of people's opinions on Michael leaving. My favorite is probably Toby.
Mm-hmm.
他说，迈克尔就像飞机上的电影。不太好，但可以看。然后当电影结束时，你会说，现在怎么办？是的。BJ写了那个采访镜头，非常有趣。我们收到了一封关于它的邮件。什么？有人写信来，我很抱歉，我没记下你的名字，说这一集的一个错失的机会是托比主持迈克尔的离职面谈。哦，你不想看到那个吗？我向亚伦提到了，亚伦说，哦，但他被护送出去了。他们喜欢相信，如果迈克尔没有被护送出去，他会在离开前和托比进行离职面谈。另外，他们写了一个非常棒的迈克尔和托比的场景，托比帮助他修改他的简历，但没被用上。是的。
He says, Michael is like a movie on a plane. Not great, but something to watch.
And then when the movie's over, you're like, now what?
Yes. BJ wrote that talking head, very funny. And we got a piece of mail about it.
What? Someone wrote in, and I'm so sorry, I did not write down your name, to say that a missed opportunity in this episode was Toby conducting Michael's exit interview.
Oh, wouldn't you have loved to see that? And I mentioned it to Aaron, and Aaron said, oh, but he was escorted out. They like to believe that if Michael hadn't been escorted out, he would have had his exit interview with Toby before he left.
Plus, they had written a pretty great Michael Toby scene where Toby helps him with his right.
resume that didn't make it in.
Yes.
好吧，当每个人都有这些非常有趣的采访镜头时，克里德有一个在拍摄草稿里但没被用上，我必须读给你听。好吧。克里德说，老克里迪又熬过了一个老板，是时候在盒子里放一颗弹珠了。然后克里德从他的桌子里拿出一个雪茄盒，放了一颗弹珠进去。盒子里有四颗弹珠。什么？那太神奇了？
Well, as everyone is having these really funny talking heads, Creed had one that was in the shooting
draft and it didn't make it in and I have to read it to you.
Okay.
Creed says, Old Creedy outlives yet another boss, time to put a marble in the box.
And then Creed pulls out a cigar box out from his desk and puts a marble in it.
There are four marbles in that box.
What?
Is that amazing?
好吧，就像你说的，安吉拉，迈克尔没有离开。他实际上从前门爬进了办公室。他去了会计部。这对我们来说是一场非常有趣的戏。真的很难不笑。我们尝试了我是如何关抽屉的，我最终用脚关上了它。这真的太有趣了。不过史蒂夫确实擦伤了他的手肘和膝盖。
Well, like you said, Angela, Michael is not leaving.
He actually army cralls through the front door, through the office.
He goes over to accounting.
This was a really fun scene for us to shoot.
It was really hard not to laugh.
We played around with how I shut the drawer and I ultimately shut it with my foot.
And it was just like so fun.
Steve really tore up his elbows and his knees, though.
是的。做那个。他像是有地毯灼伤。是的。兰迪告诉我们，他们给了他肘垫和膝垫。史蒂夫说，没关系。我会做的。他拍了两次没用肘垫和膝垫。他完全擦伤了他的手肘和膝盖。他太投入了。另外，兰迪告诉我们，你知道，当他把那个荧光笔扔向吉姆时？是的。那不是真的荧光笔。那是假的荧光笔。哦，所以它不会伤到人？是的。还记得迈克尔把笔扔向托比的额头吗？比尔不得不做一个橡胶笔。是的。菲尔不得不做一个橡胶荧光笔，花了850.50美元。哇。是的。迈克尔想让每个人都和他一起走，他开始拉菲利斯的椅子。你从查尔斯的角度看到了，对吧？你看到菲利斯有点像在倾斜，对吧？是的。向一边。如果你看花絮，伙计们，我记得这件事发生了，我们第一次拍这场戏时，史蒂夫猛拉菲利斯的椅子，她直接从上面摔了下来。哦，是的，我记得。他们没停止拍摄。你知道，
Yeah.
Doing that.
He got like a rug burn.
Yes. And Randy told us that they offered him elbow and knee pads. And Steve was like, it's fine. I'll do it. And he did two takes without the elbow and knee pads. And he totally tore up his elbows and knees. He was so committed. Also, Randy told us, you know, when he throws that highlighter at Jim?
Yeah. That was not a real highlighter. That was a faky highlighter. Oh, so it wouldn't like hurt someone? Yes. Remember when Michael throws the pen at Toby's forehead? And Bill had to make a rubber pen.
Yeah. Phil had to make a rubber highlighter and it cost $850.50. Whoa. Yep.
Michael wants everyone to go with him and he starts to pull at Phyllis's chair. And you see it from the point of view of Charles, right? You see Phyllis kind of like lurching, right? Yeah. To the side. If you watch the bloopers, you guys, and I remember this happening, the first time we did this scene, Steve yanks on Phyllis's chair and she fell right out of it.
Oh, yeah, I remember that. And they didn't stop rolling. You know,
不，迈克尔只是说，哦天哪，菲利斯，你还好吗？你还好吗？菲利斯有点哼笑，她说，是的，是的。但这在花絮里，太棒了。现在，查尔斯要找到迈克尔。是的。他从办公室出来，他们进行了这次非常尴尬的交流。是的，就像它要变得有肢体冲突一样。好了，在删减片段里，珍娜，查尔斯发现迈克尔在一个盒子里偷办公用品，并在厨房里追他。迈克尔扔掉那箱用品，想，把他们甩掉。你知道，也许查尔斯会被它绊倒。然后他，就像最后的一搏，抓起那一大桶奶酪球跑了。哦，天哪。这就是为什么我们稍后会在迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司有奶酪球。
No, Michael just goes, oh my God, Phyllis, are you okay? Are you okay? And Phyllis kind of snorts laughs, and she says, yes, yes. But it's in the bloopers and it's great.
Now, Charles is going to find Michael. Yeah. He comes out of his office and they have this really awkward exchange.
Yeah, like where it's going to get physical. All right, in the deleted scenes, Jenna, Charles finds Michael stealing office supplies in a box and chases him through the kitchen.
Michael drops the box of supplies to, like, throw them off.
You know, maybe Charles will trip over it.
And then he, like, last-ditch effort just grabs the big container of cheeseballs and makes a run for it.
Oh, my gosh.
That's why we're going to have cheese balls later in Michael's paper company.
因为在删减片段里，他带走的就是奶酪球。我喜欢它。我知道。我希望它被用上了。所以对我来说，当迈克尔说，谁和我一起？谁要和我一起？这是他的《甜心先生》时刻。不是金鱼，而是一堆奶酪球。
Because in the deleted scenes, that's what he leaves with is the cheese balls.
I love it.
I know.
I wish it had made it in.
So for me, when Michael's like, who's with me?
Who's coming with me?
This is his Jerry McGuire moment.
Instead of a goldfish, it's a bunch of cheese balls.
那太完美了。我以为我们必须听到杰里的时刻，然后是迈克尔的时刻。这个时刻将是这个被上帝遗弃的行业中真实、有趣和鼓舞人心的时刻，我们将一起做到。谁要和我一起？谁要和我一起？谁要和我一起？除了弗利珀，谁要和我一起？
That is perfect.
I thought we had to hear Jerry's moment and then Michael's moment.
This moment will be the moment of something real and fun and inspiring in this God-forsaken business,
and we will do it together.
Who's coming with me?
Who's coming with me besides flipper?
这里。我会和你一起。现在是迈克尔和帕姆的时刻。这是你的未来。你好。我是你的未来。你老了，你现在非常快乐，因为你和迈克尔·斯科特一起走了，对吧？
Here.
I will go with you.
And now for Michael and Pam's moment.
This is your future.
Hello.
I am your future.
You are older and you are very happy now
because you went with Michael Scott, right?
所以大家，下来吧。现在让我们一起爬出去，好吗？来吧。你在这里尽力了吗？你正在成为你能成为的最好的人吗？好了。所有要和我一起走的人，我希望你们跺脚。哦，不。
So everybody, come on down.
Now let's just crawl out of here together, all right?
Come on.
Are you doing your best here?
Are you being the best that you can be?
All right.
Everybody who's going to go with me, I want you to stop your foot.
Oh, no.
什么？我要和他一起走。我的意思是，来吧。哦，太像《甜心先生》了。顺便说一句，我忘了《甜心先生》里的金鱼，我要告诉你，当我们到达迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司时，我们不仅有那些奶酪泡芙，迈克尔的桌子上还有一条金鱼。
What?
I'm going with him.
I mean, come on.
Oh, it was so Jerry McGuire.
By the way, I forgot about the goldfish in Jerry McGuire,
and I'll have you know that when we get to Michael Scott Paper Company,
not only do we have those cheese puffs,
but Michael has a goldfish on his desk.
来吧。是的。好吧，粉丝们对这一集非常分歧。很多人喜欢迈克尔创办他的造纸公司和帕姆和他一起走的这一转折。但其他人真的认为帕姆在没先和吉姆商量的情况下辞职是很自私的。好吧，我们和亚伦·谢勒谈过这件事，他说了两件事。首先，他说，在未来的一集里，剧透警告，来自电话营销公司的维克拉姆，将加入迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。是的。
Come on.
Yep.
Well, fans were very split on this episode.
A lot of people loved this turn of events of Michael starting his paper company and Pam going with him.
But other people really thought that it was selfish of Pam to quit without talking to Jim first.
Well, we talked to Aaron Scher about this, and he said two things.
First of all, he said, in a future episode, spoiler alert, Vickram from the telemarketing firm, is going to join Michael Scott Paper Company.
Yes.
来吧。没错。嗯，粉丝们对这一集的看法非常分歧。很多人喜欢迈克尔创办造纸公司、帕姆随他而去这一情节转折。但也有人认为帕姆在没和吉姆商量的情况下就辞职太自私了。嗯，我们和亚伦·谢尔谈过这件事，他说了两点。首先，他说在未来的一集中，剧透预警，来自电话营销公司的维克拉姆将加入迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。是的。
He wrote this talking head for Vickram that got cut, but it explained why Vickram decided to join Michael Scott Paper Company.
And it went like this.
When you put your telemarketing career on the line, you haven't put much on the line.
And Aaron said he felt like that kind of summed up Pam as well.
Right.
That Pam wasn't quitting much of a job at all.
Well, if she could be replaced by some invisible scotch tape,
Yeah, right? Yeah.
他为维克拉姆写了一段被删掉的独白，解释了维克拉姆为什么决定加入迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。内容是这样的：当你把你的电话营销事业当成赌注时，你其实并没有押上多少筹码。亚伦说他觉得这句话也总结了帕姆的情况。没错。帕姆辞掉的并不是什么了不起的工作。嗯，如果她能被几卷隐形透明胶带取代的话，确实是这样，对吧？
There was also a line that Aaron wrote to explain this business of Pam not talking to Jim before making this decision, a little couplet of dialogue that got cut, where Jim said to Pam, shouldn't we have talked about this first?
And Pam said, you blindsided me with a house.
Ooh.
And Jim said, you're right. I'll bring your stuff home.
So he did address it, but it ended up getting.
cut. I think it was the right move to cut it because it seems like, I don't know, a real thing Pam is holding
on to that I don't think she is. No, I don't think so. As soon as Jim showed her the house,
she loved it. She felt cared for and loved. She took it on and I think she's been very happy ever since.
亚伦还写了一句台词来解释帕姆在做这个决定前没有和吉姆商量这件事，这是一段被删掉的对话，吉姆对帕姆说：我们难道不应该先商量一下吗？帕姆说：你买房子的事让我措手不及。噢。吉姆说：你说得对。我会把你的东西带回家。所以他确实处理了这件事，但最终还是被删了。我觉得删掉是对的，因为这看起来像是帕姆还在耿耿于怀的事情，但我认为她并没有。不，我不这么认为。吉姆一向她展示房子，她就爱上了。她感到被关心和被爱。她接受了这一切，我想从那以后她一直很幸福。
So I'm glad that they didn't pin that as some sort of lingering resentment for Pam.
Yeah. Pam catches up to Michael in the parking lot. She says she's coming along, but she wants to be a salesman,
not a receptionist.
And Jim's kind of surprised by that.
He's like, oh, okay.
Yeah.
And everyone is gathered again up in the conference room, and they're looking down as Pam and Michael walk away.
And as they're walking away, you can see the doubt.
所以我很高兴他们没有把这定性为帕姆心中挥之不去的怨恨。是的。帕姆在停车场追上了迈克尔。她说她要一起去，但她想当销售员，而不是前台。吉姆对此感到有点惊讶。他说，哦，好吧。是的，大家又聚集在会议室里，看着帕姆和迈克尔走远。当他们走远时，你可以看到那种怀疑。
You see this change of them being from triumphant to kind of doubt.
Right.
Well, a lot of people liken this ending to the ending of the graduate.
And spoiler alert to anyone who's never seen.
the graduate, but at the end of the movie, the character of Benjamin, who's played by Dustin Hoffman,
crashes the wedding of his love Elaine, and the two of them are running away from the church.
They're laughing together, and then they jump onto this city bus, and it's always just so
exciting, and they take their seat, and while they're sitting there, their expressions kind of
你看到了他们从胜利到怀疑的转变。没错。很多人把这个结局比作《毕业生》的结局。给没看过《毕业生》的人剧透一下，在电影结尾，达斯汀·霍夫曼饰演的本杰明闯入了他心爱的伊莱恩的婚礼，两人从教堂跑出来。他们一起大笑，然后跳上一辆城市公交车，那一幕总是让人非常兴奋，他们坐下后，当他们坐在那里时，他们的表情开始
slowly change.
It's a really famous scene.
It's so good.
Well, in the script, our stage direction for this scene was this.
Jim waves as Michael and Pam walk out together.
We stay on their faces as they transition from fantasy to reality.
So I was not thinking of the graduate when we shot this.
I was thinking of a different scene from the movie The Heartbreak Kid with Charles Groton.
慢慢改变。那是一个非常著名的场景。太棒了。在剧本中，我们这一幕的舞台指导是这样的：吉姆在迈克尔和帕姆一起走出去时挥手告别。镜头停留在他们的脸上，看着他们从幻想转变为现实。所以我们在拍摄时并没有想到《毕业生》。我想到的是查尔斯·格罗丁主演的电影《心碎度蜜月》中的另一个场景。
Have you seen it?
I mean, a long time ago.
Well, again, I guess, spoiler alert.
the end of this movie, he's finally married the woman of his dream. Sybil Shepard, he's been chasing
her through the whole movie. He sits down at a couch at their reception. And then you just see
this sort of like malaise wash over his face. And he's like, what now? Because for him,
it's all about the joy of the pursuit. But now he did it. Right. And you can tell he's already
restless. I thought of that movie because I always think that's such a perfect moment of acting.
你看过吗？我是说，很久以前了。好吧，再次剧透一下。电影结尾，他终于娶到了梦中情人西碧儿·谢泼德，他在整部电影中都在追求她。他在婚礼招待会上坐在沙发上。然后你就能看到那种倦怠感笼罩在他的脸上。他心想：现在该怎么办？因为对他来说，一切都在于追求的过程。但现在他做到了。没错。你可以看出他已经坐立不安了。我想到那部电影是因为我一直认为那是表演的完美时刻。
I mean, he's so good in that movie.
But anyway.
Well, I will tell you that Tom Cruise and Renee Zellwiger in the elevator holding a goldfish also have a moment like that.
Hey!
Because I rewatched the movie last night.
Well, this episode ends with something I absolutely love.
There's a conference room scene.
Charles is telling everyone we've lost some employees.
我是说，他在那部电影里演得太好了。但不管怎样。好吧，我要告诉你，汤姆·克鲁斯和蕾妮·齐薇格在电梯里拿着金鱼也有过类似的时刻。嘿！因为我昨晚重温了那部电影。好吧，这一集以我绝对喜欢的一个场景结束。有一个会议室场景。查尔斯告诉大家我们失去了一些员工。
We're going to have to do some shifting around.
And this is so great.
Everyone's reactions are so good.
He's like, you know what?
Kevin, you're going to be answering phones at reception.
Everyone in the room is like, what?
I know.
我们必须做一些人员调整。这太棒了。每个人的反应都太好了。他说：你知道吗？凯文，你去前台接电话。房间里的每个人都惊呆了：什么？我知道，我知道。
I am very much in the foreground of this shot.
That was on purpose because they wanted me to react, obviously.
And then he says he's going to put Stanley, who's doing his crossword, barely awake, in charge of productivity.
Dwight is like, are you kidding me?
Aaron said he pitched that idea of having Charles put Kevin in charge of the phones, which is going to pay off beautifully.
the cold open of next week's episode. But he said it just makes him giggle to think that, like,
Charles's big power move after Michael leaves is putting Kevin in charge of the phones.
Yeah. He's like, I got this place. Yeah, yeah. I know what to do.
我在这个镜头的前景中非常显眼。那是故意的，因为他们显然想让我做出反应。然后他说他要让几乎没睡醒、正在做填字游戏的斯坦利负责生产力。德怀特说：你在开玩笑吗？亚伦说他提出了让查尔斯安排凯文负责电话的想法，这将在下周的剧集开头得到精彩的回报。但他表示，想到查尔斯在迈克尔离开后的大动作竟然是让凯文负责电话，就让他忍不住咯咯笑。是的。他心想：我搞定这里了。是的，是的。我知道该怎么做。
Speaking of the next episode, ironically, it did not air for two weeks. Oh, no way.
Yes, there was a break. I just thought that was really funny. People had to really wait.
Two weeks. Yeah, this was a big cliffhanger. Also, this is the last. This is the last.
last episode that Pam was a receptionist ever.
Ever?
She never returns to the receptionist desk.
Let's finish our Scotch and Splenda.
说到下一集，讽刺的是，它两周后才播出。哦，不会吧。是的，中间停播了。我只是觉得这真的很有趣。人们真的得等上两周。是的，这是一个巨大的悬念。另外，这是帕姆作为前台的最后一集。永远吗？永远？她再也没有回到前台。让我们喝完我们的苏格兰威士忌加代糖。
To Pam, our IP receptionist.
I know.
Next up, salesman.
To Pam.
I didn't know that either.
Wow.
When we filmed this episode, I didn't know.
I didn't know that you didn't know at the time.
敬帕姆，我们最棒的前台。我知道。接下来是销售员。敬帕姆。我之前也不知道。哇。我们拍这一集的时候，我不知道。我不知道你当时不知道。
Yeah.
Well, we didn't know what was going to happen.
We didn't.
Wow.
I should have worn my T-shirt today.
that says I would save the receptionist.
Hmm.
Yeah.
是的。好吧，我们不知道会发生什么。我们确实不知道。哇。我今天应该穿上那件写着我会拯救前台的T恤。嗯。是的。
Well, listen, there were a lot of other receptionists that come along, but Pam is always going to be our favorite.
Well, thank you, ladies.
At least here on office, ladies.
Come on.
Thank you so much.
That was two weeks.
Next week is Dream Team.
I can't wait to talk about it.
好吧，听着，后来还有很多其他的前台，但帕姆永远是我们最喜欢的。好吧，谢谢你们，女士们。至少在《办公室》女士这里是这样。来吧。非常感谢。那是两周后的事了。下周是《梦之队》。我迫不及待想聊聊它了。
Please don't bring any scotch and Splenda.
We can't do it.
We can't have a Scotch and Splenda and do that podcast.
You know what I'll bring next week?
A giant pile of friendship.
toast. Oh gosh. Don't bring that either. Listen, thank you so much to Aaron Shore and Randy
Cordray for giving us all the inside details on this episode. We'll see you next week.
Bye, you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially
请不要带任何苏格兰威士忌和代糖。我们做不到。我们不能一边喝着苏格兰威士忌加代糖一边做播客。你知道我下周带什么吗？一大堆友谊吐司。哦天哪。也别带那个。听着，非常感谢亚伦·肖尔和兰迪·科德雷为我们提供了这一集的所有内幕细节。我们下周见。再见，伙计们。感谢收听《办公室》女士的第二杯。这一集最初是
created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by
Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by
Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室》女士是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的第二杯剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室》女士由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。